Es ist wieder soweit, die Ligatour Europa ist zurück und heute im XXL-Format. Wir sprechen heute mit Chris McCarthy über die Premier League, mit Daniel Zander über die Eredivisie, mit Jakob Hafke über die Liga, mit Fabian Pakulat über La Liga und mit Mario Riga über die Serie A. Ich muss das Intro abfahren. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Lyon.
Das hatte ja voll die Morning-Radio-Vibes. Es tut mir sehr leid für diese völlig exaltierte Ankündigung. Aber ihr freut euch ja auch, dass die Ligatour wieder zurück ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid und schön, dass ich hier diese große Runde habe. Einmal ein kollektives Guten Morgen, ihr Lieben.
Moin, guten Morgen.
Sehr schön.
Wie wenn man in ein Wartezimmer reinkommt, ehrlich gesagt, in einer Arztpraxis. Und ehrlich gesagt, kleiner Insider, so ein bisschen ist es ja auch wirklich hier. Wie ist denn das so? Wir haben ja hier manche Leute, die eine Winterpause hatten und für manche ist es durchgelaufen. Chris, als Premier League-Fan, wie ist das, wenn man eigentlich die ganze Zeit dran bleiben muss? Also ich habe das ehrlich gesagt schon gebraucht, bei der Bundesliga einfach mal sagen zu können, jetzt beschäftige ich mich mal zwei Wochen nicht mit Hoffenheim.
Da nutze ich meistens die Länderspielposen, muss ich sagen. Aber zwischen den Jahren war es ja diesmal gar nicht so schlimm, weil an Weihnachten wurde ja gar nicht gespielt erstmals, bzw. nur ein Spiel, glaube ich. Und von daher ging das eigentlich ganz gut diesmal, muss ich sagen.
Und dann hatte Fabian noch einen schönen Cup in Saudi-Arabien, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Wunderschön.
Ja, wunderschön. Hast du natürlich mitverfolgt, oder? Wobei, es wurden ja viele Geschichten geschrieben. Ich habe es ja umschifft, ehrlicherweise, weil ich mir gedacht habe, das interessiert mich alles nicht.
Nein, man kam nicht dran vorbei. Und es war ja auch hochst brisant mit der Geschichte um Xavi Alonso und so weiter. Also es war in der Hinsicht nicht ganz uninteressant, aber ich habe nicht so viel von den Spielen direkt gesehen, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Aber habe natürlich danach viel drüber gelesen. Und ja, hat dann auch zu einem bestimmten Ergebnis geführt, wie wir alle wissen.
Ja, genau. Da werden wir noch drüber sprechen. Und ehrlich gesagt, bei den anderen Ligen bin ich mir gerade gar nicht sicher. Mario, wie ist das in der Serie A? Gibt es da eine Winterpause? So eine kurze Pause war es, oder?
Nee, die haben am 28.12. gespielt und dann am 2.1. und Heilige Drei Könige. Und ja, aber es war ganz lustig. Als ich jetzt Napoli in Kopenhagen hatte, dann habe ich bei Kopenhagen gesehen, die hatten ja ihr letztes Pflichtspiel Mitte Dezember, weil die Norweger so eine lange Winterpause machen. Und da habe ich gedacht, warte mal, Moment mal. Als der Fußball noch normal war, da war Mitte Mitte Dezember bis Mitte Januar einfach, das war halt eine Winterpause. Und jetzt so, 4 Wochen kein Pflichtspiel, sind die überhaupt noch über Rhythmus?
Also ich kann dir sagen, da musst du nur ins Kickerarchiv gehen, so in die 60er definitiv, aber auch in den 70ern, wurde regelmäßig noch darüber diskutiert, ob man die Winterpause in der Bundesliga nicht auf drei Monate verlängern sollte und dafür dann einfach die restlichen Spiele alle im Frühjahr, weil da ständig Spiele ausgefallen sind, weil der Boden vereist war und so weiter und so fort. Und das hat die alle genervt damals. Daniel, wie ist es in der Eredivisi?
Ja, da gab es eine kleine Pause. Also vor Weihnachten war das letzte Spiel, ich glaube am 21. oder 22. und dann jetzt wieder am 10.1. Also die konnten sich ein bisschen ausruhen. Das fand ich auch ganz nett, auch noch ein bisschen abschalten zu können. Bin ich bei dir.
Aber wirklich. Und Jakob, in der Liga 1 gab es da nicht auch irgendwelche Spiele zwischendurch. Es ist immer wieder mal was an mir vorbeigeruscht. Aber ehrlich gesagt bin ich auch ganz gut drin gewesen, in diesem Winter zu sagen, ja, das erzählen mir die Jungs dann alle in der Ligatur.
Ja, es gab noch den französischen Super Cup. Das war allerdings nur ein Spiel, der war aber auch dazwischen geklemmt. Und es gab jetzt aber zweimal Pokalwochenenden. Also das war das letzte Wochenende vor Weihnachten, war Coupe de France. Da konnte man allerdings auch in Deutschland eigentlich nichts gucken. Der wird ja, ist glaube ich, bei Magenta dieses Jahr. Aber aus der Runde haben sie irgendwie noch gar nichts übertragen. Und dann war das erste Wochenende diesen Jahres, es war dann wieder Liga, dann noch mal ein Pokalwochenende. Und jetzt ist der Liga-Betrieb aber wieder richtig am Laufen auch.
Und dann war das Coupe de France, wo Paris FC gegen PSG gewonnen hat?
Genau, das war jetzt vor einer Woche oder vor anderthalb Wochen, genau. Da war auch am Pokalwochenende. Und dann Montagabend hat Paris FC dann gegen PSG gewonnen, genau.
Okay, sprechen wir später noch kurz drüber. Dann lass mal reingehen in die Themen. Fabian, du hast es schon angesprochen, Xabi Alonso bei Real Madrid ist nicht mehr Trainer. War natürlich so die größte Story auch, weil alle, die ihn in der Bundesliga verfolgt haben, sich natürlich ein bisschen die Augen gerieben haben. So dominant, wie er hier war mit Leverkusen, so dominant war er nicht bei Real Madrid. Wir haben sie auch schon ein bisschen in den letzten Folgen der Ligatour Europa abgefangen. Jetzt ist Abel Loa der neue Trainer. Was würdest du denn sagen, jetzt mit so ein bisschen Abstand, wie blickst du auf diese Trennung und jetzt dann auch auf die Entscheidung, erstmal mit Abel Loa weiterzumachen?
Also ich denke, dass es Alonso tatsächlich sehr schwer hatte bei Real, beziehungsweise der Schritt von Leverkusen zu Real war wahrscheinlich ein Step zu viel. Er hätte vielleicht noch eine Mannschaft im Zwischensegment gebraucht, um das erste Mal vielleicht mit ein paar wirklichen Weltstars zu arbeiten, wenn nichts gegen Leverkusen oder so weiter, aber Real Madrid ist halt schon ganz, ganz oben und da laufen dermaßen Gockel durch die Gegend. Dann hat man einen Präsidenten, der der Pate quasi ist in Spanien. Und das ist halt schon nochmal eine andere Ausgangssituation und die hat er vielleicht auch etwas unterschätzt, kann ich mir vorstellen. Er hatte von Anfang an ziemlich viel Gegenwind, intern in der Mannschaft, aber auch vom Präsidenten, da sind sie sich nie warm geworden. Es gab das Dauerreizthema Vinicius Junior, das nach wie vor ein heißes Thema ist bei den Königlichen. Und er hat halt einfach in den Trainingseinheiten, in Leverkusen, hat man es gesehen, wie die Spieler an seinen Lippen und an seinen Füßen nicht wegkamen, weil sie fasziniert waren, was er ihnen beigebracht hat. Und bei den Königlichen war das eben nicht so. Da haben halt viele gedacht, erzähl uns doch nichts. Wir sind doch hier in Barpeh, Bellingham, Vinicius. Also ich meine, wie man Pass spielen muss, das wissen wir schon selber. Also er hatte von Anfang an einen schweren Stand, würde ich sagen. Zu dem hat Real natürlich auch, sag ich jetzt mal, ein paar unglückliche Positionen in der Mannschaft. Die beiden Außenverteidiger-Positionen sind eigentlich entweder dauerverletzt oder da spielen eben Leute, die da eigentlich normalerweise nicht spielen. Das Mittelfeld ist nach der Ära groß, Modric etc. Kasimiro nach wie vor weit davon entfernt, wieder so stark zu sein, wie sie eben vor zwei, drei Jahren waren. Und vorne hast du halt Dauerthema Vinicius, hast den Bellingham, der jetzt zwar nach dieser Schulterverletzung wiederkommt, dem jetzt aber gerade sehr viel nachgesagt wird, dass er in Madrid gerne mal Party macht, hat auch sein Tor gegen Monaco dementsprechend mit der Trinkgeste gefeiert. Er lehnt diese Anschuldigung natürlich ab.
War Bellingham nicht damals derjenige, der als Dortmund in Leverkusen ein Tor geschossen hat, den Bierbecher gefangen hat, der auf ihn geworfen wurde von einem Fan, daraus getrunken hat und danach gesagt hat, es sei sein erster Schluck Bier gewesen? Mario, du musst doch sowas wissen. Also natürlich nur, weil du über die Bundesliga berichtest, nicht weil du so Bieraffin bist.
Ich glaube schon, ich kann mich auch noch an irgendetwas. Nee, Haarland war das, wo es diesen guten Umschnitt ins Publikum gab. Ich glaube, das Bier war Bellingham tatsächlich.
Also wenn es wirklich so wäre, dass ihr jetzt viel Party macht, dann können wir stolz drauf sein, dass ein Leverkusener Fan ihn dazu verführt hat, zumindest Bier zu trinken.
Er hat es in Deutschland gelernt, das ist doch wunderbar. Ja, auf jeden Fall, ihr habt es ja jetzt gerade mitbekommen, also es gab viele kleine Schausplätze, die dazu geführt haben, dass es für Alonso eben nicht so einfach war, sich dort durchzusetzen und der Rauswurf kam dann doch relativ überraschend, finde ich, weil ich finde in der Supercoppa haben sie es vor allen Dingen im Finale nicht schlecht gemacht, hatten Barcelona kurz davor auch in die Verlängerung zumindest zu drücken, haben dann noch mal zwei Hochkarriere vergeben, hätte also auch anders ausgehen können, aber vielleicht hat es dann auch für Tito Perez dann quasi den Ausschlag gegeben sozusagen, jetzt Alonso tatsächlich zu entlassen, der ihm ja schon länger ein Dorn im Auge war und ich glaube, wie gesagt, dass Vinicius da eine ganz große Rolle spielt, denn Alonso konnte nicht mit ihm und Vinicius hat eine ganz große, wie soll ich sagen, er muss spielen quasi. Das ist auch für Perez so der Fall. Und es gibt ja auch in Real Madrid einfach das Lager, das nicht mit Vinicius kann und es gibt das Lager, das mit ihm kann. Außerhalb von Real Madrid hassen sie ihn sowieso alle. Es ist eine sehr schwierige Figur, mit der man umgehen muss bei Real Madrid. Und genau, Arbeloa macht es jetzt ein bisschen besser mit Vinicius, in Anführungszeichen.
Also was macht er denn? Also was muss man denn besser machen mit Vinicius? Er spielt einfach immer und muss nicht verteidigen, oder?
So ungefähr, genau. Er gehört auch mit zu den Kapitänen. Er wird mit einbezogen, wie die Mannschaft spielen soll. Er ist einfach ein wichtiger Faktor in allem, was er macht. Und er soll wieder Aushängeschild sein. Und es soll egal sein, ob ihm ja Teile der Fans nicht mögen oder sogar Teile der Mannschaft nicht mit ihm können. Man hat das jetzt gegen Monaco ganz gut gesehen, dass er beim Torjubel das erste Mal seit, weiß ich nicht, wie lange, Jahren nicht den Fans gelaufen ist zum Jubeln, sondern sich zur Mannschaft bewegt hat und sich dort hat ein bisschen umarmen lassen. Da sind aber auch nicht alle Spieler hingegangen, sondern nur seine Buddies. Also es ist im Kader von Real Madrid auch nicht ganz einfach, würde ich sagen. Und naja, das alles hat eben dazu geführt, dass Alonso gehen musste und dass er jetzt Arbeloa eingestellt hat, hat für mich die logische Konsequenz, weil das einer ist, den Florian Perez von oben ein bisschen steuern kann, der sich natürlich über die Shows wahnsinnig freut, der im Endeffekt so den selben Schritt machen soll, wie Zidane, glaube ich, ist so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass er auch die zweite Mannschaft trainiert kann, dann mehr oder weniger dort ist er reingeworfen worden. Wobei der große Unterschied natürlich ist, dass Zidane schon eine andere Aura hat als Arbeloa, der in Spanien übrigens ganz gern als Warnhut oder wie nennt man diese?
Diese Pylone.
Ja, diese Dinger, die man auf der Straße aufstellt, wenn irgendwo Baustelle ist, so wird er in Spanien bezeichnet. Also bei dem wundert man sich, dass der so eine große Karriere gemacht hat, bei den ganzen Vereinen.
Ja, Moment mal, aber warum wird er so bezeichnet? Das musst du kurz…
Weil er halt nicht so wendig ist und nicht so gut. Also in Spanien ist so ein Warnhut einfach so ein Typ, der halt rumsteht und nichts kann, mehr oder weniger, und den man ganz leicht ausspielen kann. Da muss man einfach nur rumdribbeln. Das ist so ein bisschen… Hütchen heißen die, in Deutschland, oder?
Ja, okay, dann ist das keine Pylone.
Das ist…
Ich habe schon Dribblings gegen Hütchen verloren, aber das ist jetzt eine andere Geschichte.
Ja, wir alle schon. Ne, aber genau, so ist der Stand bei Real Madrid. Der Auftakt von Abeloa, wenn wir da vielleicht gleich weitergehen wollen, war ja nicht so prickelnd. Er hat erst mal im Pokal verloren, beim Zweitligisten Al-Bazette, wo vor ein paar Wochen sogar der FC Malaga gewonnen hat. Also das muss schon was heißen.
Erste Malaga-Referenz, 12 Minuten.
Ja, ich muss immer wieder rein. Du kennst mich mal.
Alles gut. Ich habe schon nach 6 Minuten einen Bayern-Witz gemacht. Also alles wie immer.
Genau. Und dann gab es dieses Ligaspiel gegen Levante, das sie 2-0 gewonnen haben. Da wurde die Mannschaft in der ersten Halbzeit ziemlich fett ausgepfiffen, auch Vinicius. In der zweiten Halbzeit hat er da ein paar Wechsel gemacht. Die Mannschaft kam dann besser rein, hat das Spiel ein 2-0 gewonnen. Und hat wahrscheinlich Arbeloa jetzt auch ein bisschen die Rückendeckung gegeben. Und jetzt dieses 6 zu 1 in der Champions League gegen Monaco hat natürlich noch mal das Ganze ein bisschen verstärkt. Wobei ich nicht einschätzen kann, Jakob, wie stark Monaco wirklich ist. Oder ob so ein 6 zu 1 nicht zu überbewertet ist.
Ja, geht so. Also Monaco hat jetzt, glaube ich, aus den letzten 10 Spielen 9 Mal nicht gewonnen. Der einzige Sieg war gegen PSG. Und ich fand jetzt Monaco auch tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht in dem Spiel. Also sind halt defensiv eine Katastrophe. Am Ende der schlechtesten Defensiven in der Liga. Deswegen kann man sich diese 6 Gegentore auch gut erklären. Aber ich fand jetzt, dass Real ja defensiv auch schon relativ große Probleme hatte. Und Courtois dann auch viel gehalten hat in dem Champions-League-Spiel.
Ja, absolut, nach wie vor defensiv ist es schwierig bei Real. Arbeloa versucht mit Juame Ni einfach so ein 6er zu installieren. Und dann quasi den 3 vorne so ein bisschen oder den 4 sogar vorne ein bisschen Rückendeckung zu geben. Dann mit Arda Guilher eigentlich so ein bisschen, er soll das Spiel leiten und so weiter. Aber das ist halt noch nicht so wirklich ausgereift. Und wie gesagt, diese beiden Außenverteidiger-Position, da spielt jede Woche wer anders. Das ist auch im Moment bei Real nicht so, nicht zu prickeln. Dann hast du halt zwei junge Innenverteidiger mit Asensio, der glaube ich 19 oder 20 ist, Haussen, der 22, 23 ist. Schwieriges Thema. Asensio wird ja auch überall angefeindet in Spanien. Der hat auch keine so ruhmreiche Vergangenheit. Also große Baustellen oder viele kleine Baustellen, wenn man so sagen will, bei Real Madrid. Genau, deswegen wird es auch keine einfache Saison. Aber trotzdem sind sie wieder in Meisterschaft.
Eben, weil das hat ja Barca so erschreckt, diese Alonso-Entlastung, dass sie gegen La Real– ist doch Real, so sie das verloren haben. Und jetzt ist es nur noch ein Punkt Rückstand für das andere Real auf Barca.
Genau. Ja, dann werden wir mal gucken, ob sich die Königlichen noch festigen. Barca ist ja auch nicht ganz so fest dieses Jahr. Also so eine Niederlage bei La Real, die war jetzt natürlich ein bisschen unglücklich gelaufen. Die haben, glaube ich, zwei oder drei Tore geschossen, die aberkannt worden sind. Und ja, das hätte auch zwei zu vier oder zwei zu fünf ausgehen können. Aber gut, das steht noch mal auf der anderen Sterne. Aber wir werden gucken, was bei Real passiert. Definitiv müssen sie im Sommer ein bisschen was machen, was das Mittelfeld anbelangt, wahrscheinlich auch in der Abwehr und wie sie das so beenden. Wir werden sehen. Champions League halte ich sie nicht für titelreif, wobei es immer noch Real Madrid ist, aber im Moment hinten fehlt es halt.
Das bleibt schon in den Fingern.
Ich wollte es einmal hier gecallt haben, dass Real die Champions League gewinnt, weil das hat ja schon mal funktioniert mit einem Trainer, wo die Mannschaft die Spieler ausstellt. Oder war das bei Jupp Heynckes so? Wo alle gesagt haben danach, eigentlich hat die Mannschaft sich selbst aufgestellt. Und wenn sie das mit Abel Loa machen. Und ich wollte mal fragen, wie wäre das, einen Trainer zu holen, der lange bei Barca gespielt hat? Das geht gar nicht, oder?
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Also es gab ja mal diese Spieler, die Figo zum Beispiel, Real, Vasa und so. Schwieriges Thema hat jetzt bei Spielern noch einigermaßen funktioniert. Da brauchst du aber echt ein dickes Fell, ne? Sonst geht es eigentlich nicht.
Sonst hätte ich gesagt, vielleicht holt man einfach Nico Pass, gemeinsam mit Zef Fabregas von Como. Aber wahrscheinlich hat Fabregas bisschen zu oft Rot und Blau getragen in seinem Leben.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, ja. Aber Nico Pass zurückholen könnte eine Option sein, natürlich, klar.
Und die Frage ist natürlich auch, wie attraktiv ist Real wirklich als Trainerjob noch? Zumindest, wenn du so einer bist, der so auf klare Strukturen, klare Abläufe, alle Arbeiten mitsteht. Weiß ich nicht.
Du hast da vorne wirklich ganz viel Anarchie. Das geht oft gut. Das ist aber halt, wenn du irgendwie kontrolliert spielen möchtest, ist halt auch schwierig. Und wie gesagt, die Personalie Vinicius ist schwierig. Mbappé will natürlich seine Dinge machen. Keine Frage, ob er noch der am ruhigsten ist. Thorsten Bellingham. Naja, es ist alles nicht so. Es ist nicht so leicht für den Trainer im Moment, bei den Königlichen.
Aber wirklich gut. Aber war es, wenn man ehrlich ist, noch nie so. Also das ist so im Kürze die Situation bei Real. Und wenn wir schon beim Trainerteam, beim Trainerteam sind, Chris, dann können wir ja auch auf die Premier League blicken. Denn da gibt es so einige, die ihren Unmut geäußert haben. Also Trainer meine ich jetzt.
Ja, richtig. Das hat sich in letzter Zeit etwas gehäuft. Also öffentliche Klarstellung, unvergümte Kritik und ja vor allem deutliche Spitzen an die Vereinsführungen. Das ist momentan so ein bisschen der Trend in der Premier League. Das hat mit Nuno Espírito Santo im September angefangen. Und jetzt gab es zuletzt wieder eine größere Welle von namhaften Kollegen, die nachgezogen sind, mit Enzo Maresca bei Chelsea, oben Amorim bei United und jetzt Oliver Glasner auch am Wochenende. Und ja, es sind so ein bisschen Trainerrevolten, die sind ein bisschen innen geworden und die sind durchaus berechtigt. Bei Chelsea hat jetzt Maresca im Dezember den Anfang gemacht. Da sprach er von den schlimmsten 48 Stunden seiner Chelsea-Karriere, beschwerte sich über die mangelnde Rückendeckung und war da etwas in die Kritik geraten. Das war der Grund dafür. Bei ihm war das Problem. Chelsea war so etwas verfrüht als Titelkandidat ausgemacht worden, nach einem guten Lauf von den Medien, von den Fans. Als sich dann so ein bisschen die Spiele und die Verletzungen auch häuften, musste er rotieren. Da konnte er die Form nicht aufrechterhalten. Aber was dann so ein bisschen rückblickend rauskam von einigen Berichten der BBC und die Aesthetik war, dass Chelsea ihn bei den Mannschaftsausstellungen so ein bisschen reinpfuschte. Zum einen, weil man verletzte Spieler ein bisschen länger schonen wollte, eine längere Rehabilitationszeit geben wollte, was ja auf den ersten Blick nicht falsch klingt. Zum anderen wurde aber auch gemunkelt, dass Márezka gewisse Spieler einsetzen sollte. Und wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen auf die Chelsea-Strategie schaut der letzten Jahre, man kauft sehr, sehr, sehr viele junge Spieler, sehr, sehr talentierte Spieler und möchte halt ihren Wert steigern. Und ja, da liegt die Vermutung natürlich nahe, dass er so ein bisschen diese, ich sag das mal bewusst provokant, Investitionen, ja, ein bisschen am Leben lassen sollte, beziehungsweise ihren Wert nicht in den Keller fallen lassen sollte. Und da hört man ja schon mal aus, es ist eigentlich ein Unding. Man hat das Gefühl, Márezka musste so ein bisschen im Portfolio managen, statt in Kader. Und das geht natürlich schief, wenn man diesen Spargrad fahren muss zwischen sportlichen Ambitionen und gleichzeitig auch dieser Strategie gerecht werden. Und man weiß auch aus früheren Tagen, Márezka ist auch ein bisschen emotionalerer Typ und sagt auch gern seine Meinung. Und das hat dann für den Frust gesorgt und seinen verletzt zum Beispiel.
Aber hatte das jetzt schon irgendwelche Konsequenzen oder war das jetzt bei Chelsea einfach nur so ein kurzer öffentlicher Schluck auf? Und jetzt muss man beobachten, wie sich Besitzer, Trainer und Team zusammen raufen die nächsten Wochen.
Also Márezka wurde ja dann kurz danach, man hat sich ja entschieden, in beidseitigen Einvernehmen die Beziehung zu beenden. Mittlerweile ist er Rosenoir-Trainer. Ja, beidseitiges Einvernehmen, man kennt es. Das war in seinem Fall dann die Konsequenz. Amorim musste auch gehen. Bei ihm war auch wenige Tage vorher so eine kleine Verbalentgleisung vorausgegangen. Man muss dazu sagen, Amorim, die Kritik an ihm war deutlich berechtiger sportlich. Also verkopfter Herangehensweise, schlechtester Punkteschnitt aller United-Trainer in der Premier League Historie. Also das war schon schlecht. Gleichzeitig hatte er auch nicht Unrecht, als er sich ein bisschen über die Transferstrategie beschwerte, Tage zuvor und auch betonte, dass er gekommen war, ein Manager zu sein und nicht ein Coach. In seiner Stellenbeschreibung stand zwar Coach, aber man versteht schon, was er meinte. Denn United wusste bei seiner Verpflichtung, dass er ein fast schon dogmatischer Verpflichter des 3-4-3-Systems ist und auch als sehr meinungsstark und stur gilt. Und trotzdem hat man bei United sehr wenig dafür getan, den Kader für seine Bedürfnisse zuzuschneiden. Er hat zwar ein paar teure Spieler bekommen, aber ein 3-4-3-Kader ist es trotzdem nicht. Im Gegenteil, gegen Ende soll auch Miteigentümer Jim Redcliffe reingesprochen haben und auch Direktor Jason Billocks, Herbil Cox, dass man mit einer Viererkette spielen sollte. Und da merkt man auch, auch hier, wie bei Mertesacker, wurde in die Arbeit reingepfuscht. Also man wollte, dass Morim der Trainer wird, aber nicht zu seinen Bedingungen, beziehungsweise man wollte den Typen am Morim verändern. Und das hat natürlich auch nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt am Wochenende, Glasner, der letzte Kandidat, der sich gegen die Vereinsführung auflehnte, sprach davon, komplett im Stich gelassen worden zu sein und dass es schwer zu überleben sei, wenn man zweimal das Herz rausgerissen bekommt. Was damit gemeint war, war, dass nach EZ im Sommer jetzt auch Mark G verkauft wurde, jeweils einen Tag vorm Spiel und dass er sowas noch nie erlebt hat, kein Verständnis dafür hat. Verständlich, auf der einen Seite muss man sagen, Glasner muss verstehen, dass ein Verein wie Crystal Palace solche Spiele auch verkaufen muss. Also es gab 100 Millionen für beide, das ist für Palace sehr, sehr viel Geld. Erst recht, weil G im Sommer jetzt ablösefrei gegangen wäre. Nichtsdestotrotz hat man aus dem Geld auch zu wenig gemacht, gerade im Sommer und Glasner musste das ausbaden. Schwacher Kader, dünner Kader. Und da merkt man jetzt, dass dreimal in Folge, also in diesen drei Beispielen jeweils der Trainer in die Arbeit reingefuscht bekommt. Aber der Trainer natürlich jeweils auch den Kopf hinhalten muss und das Ganze verantworten muss.
Okay, Fabian möchte was fragen.
Ja, ich möchte noch ganz kurz dich zu West Ham fragen. Die haben ja auch einen Trainerwechsel vollzogen. Und da ist ja ein Spanier herangekommen. Sehr überraschend für uns, Paco Jemes. Der hat nicht mal mehr bei dem Zweitligisten in Spanien mehr einen Vertrag bekommen. Gilt als sehr charismatische Figur, um das mal positiver auszudrücken. Hat jetzt aber sein erstes Spiel gewonnen, oder Chris?
Ja, richtig, das ist auch mein zweites Thema heute übrigens bzw. nicht West Ham, nicht West Ham, aber Tottenham. Und dann sieht man auch schon, dass die Leistungen jetzt, wie soll ich sagen, Tottenham war auch nicht sonderlich gut drauf zuletzt. Von daher sollte man das noch nicht so hoch hängen, um das jetzt mal kurz anzuteasen.
Sprechen wir gleich noch drüber. Okay, Jakob, ich sehe einfach gar keine Fragen mehr. Ich teile nur auf das Wort, wie in der UN hier.
Jakob? Ich finde, in England ist ja ganz interessant, was– also in Deutschland ist es ja etablierter bei dem öffentlichen Auftritt der Trainer, dass man auch die Sportdirektoren und so sieht in der Öffentlichkeit. Und ich frage mich immer so ein bisschen, ob das vielleicht auch in England ein Teil des Problems ist, dass die Trainer eigentlich den gesamten öffentlichen Druck aushalten müssen und einerseits ja noch dieses, okay, es gibt die Übermanager, wie früher Sir Alex Ferguson und Arsene Wenger. Und dann ist es natürlich auch, wenn man alles bestimmt, muss man auch alles vertreten in der Öffentlichkeit. Aber jetzt ist ja bei vielen Vereinen so, dass sie schon auch versuchen, Sportdirektorenmodell zu etablieren. Und aber man weiß ja überhaupt nicht, wer das ist. Also ich weiß nicht, wie Jason Wilcox aussieht. Ich weiß, dass der irgendwann mal Premier League gespielt hat bei United. Also aber keine Ahnung, wer das wirklich ist. Und der steht auch nicht in der Öffentlichkeit. Und dann muss Amorim alles ausbaden. Auch die Transfers werden den Trainern vorgeworfen und so. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das schon auch so ein großer Teil des Spannungsfelds ist.
Genau. Das ist auch so ein bisschen mein Fazit der gesamten Sache. Ich habe jetzt lange gebraucht, um da hinzuführen, indem ich die drei Weispiele so ein bisschen skizziert habe. Aber das ist genau mein Punkt. Ich habe vor kurzem ein Zitat von Gareth Southgate gesehen, der sagte, die Erosion der Autorität von Trainern ist ein schleichender Prozess, der sich über viele Jahre hinweg vollzogen hat. Und er hat das gar nicht so kritisch gesehen. Aber was er damit meinte, ist eben, was du sagst, dass die Bedeutung und der Einfluss vor allem von Direktoren und auch von anderen Abteilungen in einem Fußballverein, sei es Scouting, sei es Sportwissenschaften, sei es Finanzen etc., dass die Bedeutung dieser Abteilung alle wachsen. Und wie du sagst, es ist trotzdem immer der Trainer, der den Kopf hinhält. Es ist trotzdem der Druck, der lastet auf einem Trainer. Und er muss sich meistens für eine Gesamtsituation verantworten, obwohl er nicht für die Gesamtsituation verantwortlich ist. Und man sieht es im Stadion, da ist der Trainer natürlich der Erste, der den Wut der Fans abbekommt. Man sieht es in der Presse, er muss die Pressekonferenz leiten, auch wenn er vielleicht jetzt über einen Kader managt, den er nicht so zusammengestellt haben wollte oder der nicht zu seiner Spielidee passt. Oder im Fall von Chelsea, weil er Bedingungen oder Kompromisse moderieren muss, die er nicht verursacht hat. Und das genau ist das Problem, was derzeit in England herrscht. Und dementsprechend muss man sagen, viele Leute sagen dann immer, ja, was beschweren die sich? Die sind ja auch Millionäre oder sehr reich etc. Aber das ist ja nicht Sinn der Sache. Die Leute wollen ihre Passion ausführen, ihren Job ausführen, bekommen reingepfuscht und werden dann für Sachen kritisiert, die sie zumindest nur zum Teil verbockt haben. Und dementsprechend ist der Frust groß und dementsprechend werden diese Revolten bestimmt auch so weitergehen.
Ja, ist wirklich interessant. Ich meine, da stecken immer noch ganz viele einzige Schichten drin. Also bei Oli Glasner ist es ja fast schon... Ja. Also sinnbildlich, er hatte bei Wolfsburg Probleme, er hatte bei Eintracht Frankfurt Probleme genau hinsichtlich, dass er nicht zufrieden war mit dem Kader. Jetzt bei Crystal Palace auch. Aber ich würde eben auch sagen, das hat hier eine komplett andere Qualität. Auch eben wegen der Terminierung von Wechseln. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Premier League da einfach viel, viel brutaler ist, dass dir halt wirklich vor einem wichtigen Spiel noch ein Spieler weggekauft werden kann. Hier in Deutschland wäre es wenigstens so. Erinnern wir uns zum Beispiel Oma Mamouche wechselt zu City. Er steht dann nicht im Spieltagskader an diesem Tag. Dann wissen alle, okay, er wechselt. Und dann danach verabschiedet er sich noch und geht dann. Und das ist klar, hat er dann auch nicht gespielt. Aber das ist dann doch noch mal ein ganz anderes Gefühl für alle Beteiligten. Ich glaube auch für die Mannschaftsteam-Mitglieder, als es eben so wie in der Premier League ist, dass jemand einfach weg ist von jetzt auf gleich. Und egal, ob es der Kapitän ist oder nicht.
Genau. Und dementsprechend emotional und auch– trotz der Kürze, die jetzt negativ an war– aber Glasner's Reaktion darauf. Ich fand das ganz witzig. Er hat am Freitag ja schon bekannt gegeben, dass er seinen auslaufenden Vertrag nicht verlängern wird. Am Samstag war dann das Spiel. Und er hat tatsächlich komplett auf Auswechslung verzichtet, obwohl seine Mannschaft wirklich auf den Zahnfleisch geht. Und er sagte zwar, auf der Bank war jetzt nicht viel da, aber da waren schon ein paar Leute, die hätten einspringen können. Also im Bonassosa war zum Beispiel auch auf der Bank, gab es schon ein paar Kandidaten. Und dann wurde ihn gefragt, wie es jetzt bis zum Saisonende aussieht mit ihm, ob er jetzt bleibt, wie es weitergeht, blablabla. Und da war seine Antwort einfach nur mir egal. Dementsprechend hat man eigentlich stark damit gerechnet, dass auch Glasner das Wochenende nicht überleben würde. Aber witzigerweise war Glasner derjenige, der sich am weitesten aus dem Fenster lehnte, aber seinen Job behielt. Ich weiß nicht, ob man bei Crystal Palace dachte, der blöfft. Ich denke viel eher, dass man bei Crystal Palace einfach weiß, was für eine fantastische Arbeit Glasner macht, aus wenig Mitteln und dass man das zumindest bis zum Saisonende aufrechterhalten möchte, damit man nicht noch irgendwie unten reinrutscht. Man spielt ja auch noch in der Conference League gerade. Also ja, ist auch so ein bisschen Machtkampf, glaube ich, zwischen Steve Parrish und Glasner.
Ja, und da muss man ehrlicherweise schon sagen, also an dem Punkt, da verscherzt das sich natürlich dann schon mit seinem Team, weil er hat ja auch darüber gesprochen, auf meiner Bank, da sitzen nur Kids, also da sitzen nur Kinder und du sagst es eben, da saßen eben auch erfahrene Spieler und im letzten Spiel hat er gar nicht gewechselt, im vorletzten Spiel hat er einmal gewechselt, eben genau jeden Borna Sosa in der 90. Minute. Also, worüber reden wir hier? Das ist schon eindeutig, das ist schon Kategorie, Felix Magath wechselt beim 5 zu 1 gegen Bayern nochmal den Torhüter ein. Also, da kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass da keine Botschaft drin steckt, in dem Fall dann nicht ausgebliebenen Wegsinn. Und das sendet natürlich ein Signal an alle diejenigen, die nicht eingewechselt werden.
Genau. Es ist auch ein bisschen vereinsschädigend oder rufschädigend für den Verein. Weil wenn du jetzt neue Trainer anziehen möchtest, etc., dann oder neue Spieler verpflichten möchtest, du strahlst halt auch aus, dass es bei dir im Verein einfach nicht stimmt. Und das ist halt auch so ein bisschen ein Problem an der Geschichte. Unter dem Strich, man kann das Verhalten von Glasner in dem Fall kritisieren, tun auch sehr viele Fans mittlerweile. Sie haben auch so ein bisschen die Schnauze voll. Ein Lager zumindest. Fand es auch ganz interessant, er versprach in der dritten Person von sich, in manchen Situationen in der dritten Konferenz. Also da ist er schon, er hat die Schnauze voll, sagt man ja auf gut Deutsch. Aber ich finde, es unterstreicht einfach auch wieder diese Ohnmacht und auch den Frust, um auf das Fazit zurückzukommen, dass Glasner einfach da genug hat, dass er so eingeschränkt wird. Und vor allem, wie es jetzt auch vielleicht bei Würzburg und Frankfurt war, dass auch so ein bisschen der Verein mit seinen Ambitionen einfach einen Schritt halten kann.
Ja, er müsste jetzt zu einem Verein wechseln, wo ihm die Spieler nicht mehr weggekauft werden, zumindest nicht mehr so häufig. Und eigentlich hat er sich da ja schon hintrainiert. Ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher, ob er durch diese öffentliche Kommunikation sich da nicht vielleicht wieder eine Tür zugemacht hat. Denn gerade diese Vereine werden ja dann von Ownern, also von Besitzern geführt oder sind aus sich selbst heraus so selbstbewusst, dass sie das jetzt nicht unbedingt haben wollen, dass da so viel kritisiert wird. Ich meine, schaut euch an, was hier in Deutschland los war, als Thomas Tuchel eine Holding Six gefordert hat. Das ist, naja, okay. Aber interessantes Thema, diese Trainer. Und wir bleiben auch bei Trainern und gehen nochmal in die Ehre Divisi, Daniel. Und zwar zu ALKMA, die 6 zu 0 im Pokal gegen Ajax gewonnen haben. Das heißt, du wirst uns jetzt bestimmt erzählen, Ajax hat mal wieder den Trainer danach wechseln müssen.
Wie das war Aset tatsächlich. Jetzt haben wir so solche Geschichten. Die schreibt der Fußball immer ordentlich in das Phrasenschweiz und das Zahnlein. Also, ich finde es teilweise absurd, was da passiert ist. Also genau, vergangene Woche hatte Aset gegen Ajax 6 zu 0 im Pokal gewonnen. Auch verdient. Das war jetzt nicht irgendwie glücklich. Ich meine, es war 6 zu 0, das will man da großartig glücklich nennen. Insofern, das war schon beeindruckend. Es lag natürlich nicht nur an Aset und dann auch an Ajax, die ja weiterhin von Problemen überzogen sind. Ich habe mir vorgenommen, mal in dieser Folge Rasenfunk nicht über Ajax zu reden.
Kaum haben sie gewonnen, du alter Hater. Aber das konnte man ja wirklich nicht ahnen. Noch lange Zeit, gestern nicht.
Ja, lag ja auch erst wieder hinten. Also ich dachte eigentlich gestern auch schon. Na ja, gut. Und Aset hat also diesen wirklich grandiosen Sieg gefeiert und haben dann Post-Win in der Liga gegen Zwolle 3-1 verloren. Und ich glaube, dass nach so einem 6-0-Sieg gegen Ajax die diese Enttäuschung über diesen 3-2-1-Sieg gegen Zwolle noch mal größer gemacht hat, als er eigentlich so bewertet ist. Und in der Tat musste dann Martin Martens– Herr Aussagener name– sein Gut nehmen bei Aset. Und es ist aus verschiedenen Gründen eigentlich nicht wirklich nass zu verziehen. Also in der Liga läuft es dann nicht so gut offenkundig, sind aber auch jetzt nur siebter, haben drei Punkte Rückstand auf vier. Also die ist auch nicht irgendwie abgeschlagen oder ziehen da einsamere Kreise im Mittelfeld. Also die haben sechs Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz zehn. Platz zehn ist der Platz, der in der Liga nicht mehr berechtigen würde für irgendwelche europäischen Quali-Grunden. Und Platz vier ist eine sichere Quali für die Europa League. Also die sind da immer noch relativ nah dran. Und vor dieser Nierlage gegen Zwolle haben sie auch gewonnen in der Liga, gegen Wohldamm. Und der Grund, warum man jetzt gehen musste, liegt zum Wissen in den Spielen davor. Also ja, sie haben jetzt gewonnen gegen Wohldamm. Aus den letzten sieben Ligaspielen haben sie aber vier Punkte geholt. Also die Sieg gegen Wohldamm und davor nochmal ein Unentschieden gegen Diventa. Und davor lief dann in der Tat nicht mehr so viel. Man muss aber dazu eben auch sagen, das waren oft auch knappe Spiele. Also sie haben dann gegen Fortuna Sintard verloren mit 4 zu 3. Also auch nur ein Torunterschied. Hatten sie auch noch ein bisschen Spielpech. Also haben da auch ein Elfmeter verschossene gehalten wurde. Vielmehr bei dem 2 zu 2 gegen Diventa vor einigen Wochen haben sie in der 80. dann den Ausgleich noch gekriegt. Also es ist auch nicht so, dass die Spiele, die sie jetzt verloren haben davor oder nicht gewonnen haben davor, ein Offenbarungseinspielerisch war. Es war einfach auch oft so eine Phase, in der du einfach kein Spiel Glück so ein bisschen hast. Und das hat trotzdem jetzt gereicht für Altmaier, dass sie gesagt haben, nein, wir möchten uns verändern. Wir möchten, wie es schon heißt, neue Impulse haben. Das habe ich oft auch für eine sehr furchtbare Fass gelieft. Und ja, also klar, fußballerisch war es jetzt auch nicht ein Feuerwerk offenkundig. Man kann Martens durchaus vorwerfen, dass er so ein bisschen zu risikoreich reagiert hat. Also was das Thema Konterabsicherung angeht, hat er da oft sehr darauf verzichtet. Oder zumindest wirkte es so, man muss sagen, dass die Abstimmung in der Defensive in den letzten Wochen nicht so da war. Das heißt, er hat schon 4-3-3 aus der Gärne spielen lassen mit sehr aktiven Außenverteidigern. Da muss ich im Mittelfeld wieder reinfallen lassen. Und da war die Abstimmung in den letzten Wochen einfach nicht so da. Aber das ist aus meiner Sicht nichts, was jetzt nicht irgendwie mittelfürziert so beheben wäre. Also er hatte vor zwei Jahren im 24 auch schon mal so eine Phase gehabt, wo er mehrere Wochen ohne Sieg geblieben ist mit ähnlichen Motiven. Und da kam er ja auch wieder raus damals. Also für mich ist das ein viel zu reaktionärer Entschluss von Altmar.
Also ist es von allen Asett-Trainer, die mehr als 100 Spieler haben, hat er den fünf besten Punkteschnitt. Den besten Punkteschnitt hat übrigens Georg Kessler. Wer sich noch an den Namen erinnert, der ist entweder Hertha-Fan, denn da war er mal Trainer, oder einfach sehr firm im Fußball der 70er. Das muss man dazu sagen, aber das nur am Rande.
Ja, du sagst es, für mich ist Martin Martens eigentlich so ein Prototyp Asett-Trainer, der die Philosophie von dem Verein eigentlich echt gelebt hat und vorbildlich umgesetzt hat. Also Asett ist ein Club, ein kleinerer Club, also es ist quasi so ein, wie heimlich, Topper, also Ajax-Fan, PSV, wie das normal läuft. Deswegen habe ich Ajax noch jetzt aufgezählt. Und Asett ist so ein Club, der die Anspruchshaltung hat, quasi Best of the West zu sein, so vielleicht mit Zwente nebenbei noch. Und das schaffen sie ja vor allem über Jugendarbeit und Clue-Transfers, den man jetzt nicht kennt. Da kommt dann wieder irgendwer aus der kroatischen Liga, den man vorher nicht kennt und der dann wieder für 20 Böden verkauft. Und wenn man sich die Verkäufe anguckt, wir haben Reinders, der 23. Milan ging. Jetzt was ihr hier seht, ist, wir haben Kerkis, aktuell bei Liverpool, der hat sein Durchbruch auch bei AZ. 24, Pavlidis bei Belfika jetzt. Oder auch 25 jetzt vergangenes Jahr, haben wir Poku jetzt in Leverkusen. Wir haben Rügen van Bommel zu PSV, Adai in Como. Das sind alle Spieler, die bei AZ quasi ihren Durchbruch hatten und dann für sehr viel Geld gewechselt sind. Und Martens hat es in den letzten Jahren hinbekommen, eben diese Lücken zu füllen. Ich meine, das bringt natürlich AZ viel Geld, aber diese Spieler müssten ja auch irgendwie ersetzt werden. Und AZ ist kein Club, der dann für große Summen Spieler kauft, die eins zu eins funktionieren sollen, sondern es sind dann eben wieder der eigene Nachwuchs. Es sind dann wieder die kreativen Transfers, die kommen, die eine Anlaufzeit brauchen. Und es ist eigentlich schon rückblickend beeindruckend, dass das die letzten Jahre immer so relativ freibungslos funktioniert hat. Und dann, finde ich, kann man es nicht erwarten, dass es eben die nächsten zehn Jahre auch so freibungslos weitergeht. Und deswegen dann bei dem kleinen Leistungsziech, was sie ohne Zweifel haben, da jetzt aber zu sagen, ne, wir wollen was Neues versuchen, finde ich ein bisschen überstürzt. Das Einzige, was man vielleicht fürhalten kann, ist, dass der Zeitpunkt vielleicht, wenn man es machen will, dann auch jetzt, mit einer der besten ist ein Anführungszeichen, jetzt kommen, also sie hatten gestern das Nacho-Spiel gegen Excelsior, auch nur 1-1, so zu sagen. Und danach kommt Telstar, ein Aufsteiger, und dann Neumehren, also vor allem über die, über die man sich selbst auch sieht. Das heißt, jetzt sind die wichtigen Big-Point-Spiele für ALKMA, wenn sie oben dran bleiben wollen, könnte man vielleicht sagen, vor diesem Spiel wollte man dann anscheinend nochmal was machen. Aber eigentlich finde ich nicht, dass das so klug ist. Na gut, aber das ist so, eigentlich war es so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, bei diesen Abgängen, also du hast sie ja gerade genannt, ich muss sie nicht wiederholen, und bei den Bilanzen, die dann AZ hatte, nämlich immer Platz 4 oder 5 in den letzten Jahren, wäre er doch ein super Eintrachttrainer. Da hat er genau das zu erfüllen.
Ja, also ich meine, das habe ich auch, weil man bei meiner tieferen Recherche mit dem Spunzel registriert, wenn AZ einen Trainer rauswirft, ist eigentlich immer eine große Karriere für den Trainer. Oder zumindest eine gute Karriere für den Trainer drinnen. Wir haben Arne Slott, der wurde auch mal ausgeschmissen bei AZ. Da hat er jetzt auch einen ganz guten Weg eingeschlagen. Insofern, mal gucken, also, ja, in der Tat, wäre er auf jeden Fall ein Trainerverein.
Louis van Raal, Dick Advocat, kommt auch noch daher. Also, na gut, haben wir doch schon wieder so ein kleines Nugget für alle Eintracht-Fans, die die Ligatour gehört haben. Könnte jetzt in der nächsten Stammtischrunde glänzen. Das war es aber jetzt mit den Trainerentlassungen aus. Ich habe irgendeines der Nebenthemen gerade vergessen. Zumindest jetzt wollen wir mal über was anderes sprechen. Wir gehen mal nach Frankreich, Jakob, und da haben wir eine Positivgeschichte über Olympique Lyon. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Ich meine, wir haben ja in der ersten Folge dieser Saison schon über Lyon gesprochen und da haben wir ja über sehr, sehr viel Chaos neben dem Platz gesprochen und viel Unklarheit und so. Aber ja auch da schon mit der Einschränkung, dass es sportlich ja einen ganz guten Saisonstart gab. Und entgegen aller Erwartungen ging es fast nahtlos so weiter. Also es ist wirklich extrem beeindruckend, was Lyon für eine Saison spielt. Sie stehen jetzt in der Liga auf Platz 4, haben nur zwei Punkte Rückstand auf Olympique Marseille auf Platz 3. Also Champions League Qualifikation absolut im Bereich des Möglichen. Und man darf nicht vergessen, sie spielen ja auch noch Europa League, sind da Tabellen-Erster in der Ligatabelle. Also ganz fantastische europäische Kampagne auch von ihnen. Im Pokal haben sie jetzt auch in der letzten Runde als einer der ersten Erstligisten schon gegen einen anderen Erstligisten spielen müssen, haben da auch gewonnen gegen Lille, also auch eines der Spitzen-Teams aus der Liga. Also man kämpft an drei Wettbewerben und das auch bisher sehr, sehr erfolgreich. Aber mit einem Kader, wenn man sich den anguckt, fragt man sich wirklich, wie das funktioniert. Mir ist es etwas schleierhaft, wie Paulo von Zika das schafft, mit Lyon so erfolgreich zu sein in dieser Saison. Es ist wirklich beeindruckend. Wir hatten ja im Sommer darüber gesprochen, dass sie aufgrund finanzieller Einschränkungen Spieler verkaufen mussten. Zwischenzeitlich gab es ja auch mal eine komplette Transfersperre für Neuzugänge, beziehungsweise die wurde ja immer mal so modifiziert. Mal durfte man nur keine Ablöse zahlen, mal durfte man nur leihen. Jetzt inzwischen ist diese Transfersperre aufgehoben. Das wurde, meine ich, kurz vor Weihnachten bekannt gegeben, dass sie wieder einkaufen dürfen. Jetzt im Winter allerdings, es gibt immer noch Beschränkungen. Die Geheilsmasse ist weiterhin von der DNCG eingeschränkt worden. Aber man hat jetzt auch ein paar Neuzugänge geholt. Da fällt natürlich zuallererst ins Auge, dass man mit Endrick einen durchaus, ich glaube, man kann ihn als Supertalent oder zumindest vermeintlich Supertalent bezeichnen von Real, ausgeliehen hat jetzt für die Rückrunde. Und natürlich, wie sollte es auch anders sein? So wie es bei Lyon momentan läuft, ist er auch direkt super gut eingeschlagen, hat im Pokal ein Tor vorbereitet, hat in der Liga getroffen, also, was für ein Einstand. Ne, andersrum, er hat im Pokal getroffen und in der Liga ein Tor vorbereitet. Und es aber hat in den beiden Spielen, in denen er jetzt zum Einsatz gekommen ist, direkt gezeigt, dass er der Mannschaft richtig viel geben kann. Denn bei aller Sportlichen, bei einem sportlichen Erfolg muss man schon sagen, man hat immer wieder gedacht, okay, ein Stürmer würde der Mannschaft sehr, sehr gut tun. Denn mit Malek Fofana und Ernest Nuhama fallen ja zwei, also die beiden offensiven Flügelspieler schon seit immer. Also Fofana hat sich kurz nach Saisonstart verletzt, Nuhama fehlt schon die ganze Saison und die sind gar nicht dabei. Und in der Offensive fehlte ihnen dann schon sehr, sehr viel. Auch wenn da zum Beispiel so ein Afonso Moreira, den sie im Sommer geholt haben aus Lissabon von Sporting Club, das der auch überraschenderweise sehr, sehr gut eingeschlagen hat. Aber ansonsten war dann doch häufig das Tolisso, die Tore schießen musste, zumindest zum Saisonstart. Und mit Endrick hat man jetzt einen, der wirklich bisher richtig gut reinpasst, wahnsinnig viel macht. Ich glaube, jeder, der ihn schon mal hat spielen sehen, weiß auch, dass er wirklich auch ein Spieler ist. Bei dem macht es einfach Spaß, zuzugucken. Der nimmt sich auch mal aus 30 Metern einen Schuss und der hat ja auch eine wahnsinnige linke Klebe. Das ist wirklich richtig cool. Da hat er im Pokal auch fast schon direkt ein absolutes Traumtor geschossen. Ich glaube, da kann man sich jetzt in der Rückrunde auf jeden Fall darauf freuen, ihn häufiger zu sehen. Und ein Spieler, über den man, wenn man über die Offensive spricht, auch auf jeden Fall sprechen muss, ist Pavel Sulc, der jetzt nicht mit so sonderlich vielen Vorschusslehrer-Bären im Sommer aus Tschechien gekommen ist. Der hat auch vergleichsweise wenig gekostet, also 7,5 Millionen für einen offensiven Mittelfeldspieler. Der ist jetzt 25, also auch noch nicht so sonderlich alt. Und der spielt bisher auch wirklich eine richtig gute Saison. Der wird in Frankreich so ein bisschen als tschechischer Thomas Müller manchmal bezeichnet. Und ich finde tatsächlich, dass es von der Spielweise her auch, ja, es ist jetzt kein Thomas Müller, keine Thomas-Müller-Kopie. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein ziemlich einzigartiger Spieler natürlich. Aber ich kann den Gedanken schon nachvollziehen, denn er ist auch so ein Spieler, bei dem man gar nicht so richtig weiß, auf welcher Position er eigentlich spielt oder wo er spielen müsste. Er hat jetzt bei Lyon auch häufig mal so als falsche Neun, will ich es auch nicht so richtig nennen, aber halt im Sturm nominell gespielt, obwohl er kein richtiger Stürmer ist. Er kann aber auch von der Außenbahn kommen oder aus dem offensiven Mittelfeld und hat jetzt wirklich gute Scorer-Quoten bei Lyon, schießt regelmäßig seine Tore. Gerade jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten hat man das Gefühl, dass er komplett angekommen ist in der Liga und da jetzt schon so der wichtigste Mann ist bei Lyon in der Offensive. Jetzt seitdem Endrick da ist, hat Paulo von Zicca auch auf einen 4-4-2 mit Raut umgestellt. Auch ein ganz cooles System, finde ich persönlich zumindest. Ein System, was sehr interessante Möglichkeiten bietet. Und da hat er halt aus der 10er-Position eigentlich sämtliche Freiheiten. Und vorne dann mit Endrick und Alfonso Moreira, die jetzt auch keine klassischen Mittelstürmer sind, sondern dann auch sehr viel bewegen, auf die Außenbahnen rausgehen und damit dann auch die Gegner vor Probleme stellen. Und ich bin jetzt wirklich gespannt, wie Lyon auch die Rückrunde gestaltet, ob diese hohe Belastung, die sie ja auch haben mit den drei Wettbewerben, sich noch mal recht und sie irgendwann noch mal einbrechen. Man hatte eigentlich das Gefühl, dass sie vielleicht im November, dass es dann endlich so war, endlich in Anführungsstrichen, soweit ist. Da hatten sie nämlich mal einen zwischenzeitlichen Hänger, haben sich dann aber wieder gefangen. Und da gebührt schon auch so ein bisschen der Anteil. Paulo von Seca, der Trainer, der er lange auch gar nicht an der Seitenlinie war, jetzt aber seit November auch endlich wieder sein Team von der Seitenlinie auch begleiten darf bei den Spielen.
Also ab dem Moment, da hat er dann mal kurz schlecht, lief sich das richtig? Oder kam er erst nach den Spielen?
Nee, da ist er, da kam er an die Seitenlinie, dann lief es schlecht und er hat das dann aber auch wieder korrigiert. Das hat natürlich auch durchaus für Belustigung gesorgt, dass es dann nach monatelangem Erfolg schlechter lief, als er wieder an der Seitenlinie war. Aber er hat auch taktisch dann ein bisschen was ausprobiert, zwischenzeitlich mal mit einer Dreierkette gespielt, was nicht so super funktioniert hat. Jetzt hat er dieses 4-4-2 mit Rauthe gefunden. Mal schauen, ob das jetzt die Dauerlösung bleibt, aber ich finde es schon ganz interessant. Und er macht halt aus einigen Spielern echt wahnsinnig viel. Also wir haben jetzt viel über die Offensive geredet, Lyon hat aber auch die drittbeste Abwehr der Liga, und auch wenn man sich da die Namen anguckt, es ist jetzt nicht so die absolute internationale Spitzenklasse. Also im Tor Dominic Greif macht einen sehr soliden, souveränen Job. Hatte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt damit gerechnet, zumindest mit dem, was man... Also er ist mir jetzt in Spanien nicht sonderlich ins Auge gefallen als herausragender Torwart. In der Innenverteidigung spielt Moussa Niakate eine wirklich starke Saison, den man ja auch von Mainz noch kennt. Und der ist für mich einer der besten Innenverteidiger der Liga in dieser Saison. Dann gibt es auch noch Abna, einen 25-jährigen Brasilianer. Der ist eigentlich Linksverteidiger, hat jetzt aber auch manchmal im Mittelfeld gespielt, hat auch schon fünf Tore gemacht, wettbewerbsübergreifend. Auch so ein bisschen so ein heimlicher Held bei Lyon momentan. Ja, und ansonsten ist dann auch von der Substanz her schon gar nicht mehr so viel vorhanden, dass es schon echt beeindruckend ist. Gerade auch, wenn man sich dann die Kader der Konkurrenz anguckt, also zum Beispiel von Monaco oder auch von Straßburg, die jetzt aber allesamt hinter Lyon stehen. Da würde ich dann den Lyoner-Kader eher im vielleicht oberen Mittelfeld, aber nicht unbedingt in den Champions League-Plätzen einordnen. Und so dahingehend ist es schon echt stark.
Aber wirklich vom Zwangsabstieg, dem zwischenzeitlichen, an die Spitze der Europa League-Tabelle und auf Rang 4 in der Liga, das ist nicht so schlecht. Und eine letzte kurze Verständnisfrage ist, man dazu gezwungen, vom Lyoner-Kader zu sprechen, damit man nicht vom Lyoner-Kader spricht und die alle als Würstchen bezeichnet. Oder ist das jetzt nur Zufall gewesen?
Möglich, möglich. Es kann aber auch nur Zufall gewesen sein. Und Lyon hat jetzt auch tatsächlich, um diesen Kader zu ergänzen, für die Offensive auch im Winter mit Noah Nathai noch einen geholt. Einen Namen, auf den man durchaus mal achten kann. Der war ja bei sehr, sehr vielen im Gespräch. Ein 20-jähriger Offensiver-Mittelfeldspieler aus Dänemark, von Brøndby gekommen, ist der Bruder auch von Nicolas Nathai, also vom Stuttgarter. Und genau bei dem bin ich gespannt, ob der nicht auch jetzt in der Rückrunde nochmal eine Rolle spielen wird, auch wenn er jetzt erst mal noch zwei Spiele aufgrund einer Rotsperre fehlt, die er mitgebracht hat.
Ja, also Lyon lohnt auf jeden Fall einen Blick. Und dann haben wir auch noch Ruben Kloywert da ja rumlaufen. Aber ich will nicht schon wieder dieses Thema aufmachen, weil ich weiß, dann wird die Sendung um eine Stunde länger. Also Lyon, wirklich, wirklich überraschend, wie sich das getan hat. Dann blicken wir noch Mario in die Serie A. Was gibt es denn aus Italien zu berichten?
Ja, ich glaube, fangen wir mit einem Vielgut. Jetzt hätte ich fast Füllgut-Thema gesagt. Oh Gott, Hilfe. Aber bin ich ja richtig hier aufgehoben. Aber wirklich. Niklas Füllkrug, der ein oder die andere, werden es schon mitbekommen haben, ist zur AC Milan gewechselt, aber jetzt auch so endgültig angekommen mit seinem ersten Tor vor heimischer Kulisse nach Einwechslung. Es war das Siegtor zum 1-0 gegen Lecce in einem Spiel, in dem sich Milan mal wieder sehr schwer getan hat, Tore zu schießen. Und jetzt haben sie so diesen klassischen Neuner, der ja auch in den letzten Jahren im modernen Fußball ein wenig in Verruf geraten ist, der aber, gerade wenn man so Fußball spielen lassen möchte wie Max Allegri, glaube ich schon noch sehr wichtig werden kann, auch über die gesamte Saison gesehen. Vielleicht ja dann auch für eine Turniermannschaft später im Sommer. Ja, also er hat sich da sehr gut eingefunden, wirkt sehr gut akzeptiert bei der Mannschaft, sind wirklich auch alle inklusive Ersatzspieler. Klar war auch ein 1-0 spät im Spiel, aber die Jubeltaube war groß. Er wird auf Social Media da von den Fans abgefeiert. Hat mich tatsächlich überrascht, dass das jetzt so gut funktioniert hat, weil er auch in den ersten Spielen, denen er eingewechselt wurde, immer sehr schnell wieder von dieser Qualität gebraucht gemacht hat, die er ja hat. Also auf eine ganz besondere Art und Weise Bälle festzumachen oder auch so zweite Bälle für Mitspieler zu forcieren. Also so eklig in Zweikämpfe zu gehen, dass dann der Ball, der wegspringt, bei irgendjemandem anderen landet. Ich hatte ihn jetzt halt bei West Ham gar nicht verfolgt, ehrlicherweise. Und da muss man ja auch sagen, hat er wieder, glaube ich, auch wenig Spielzeit gehabt, weil er oft verletzt ist. Das ist halt Thema seiner Karriere. Und finde ich, finde ich tatsächlich ganz schön, jetzt auch, weil ich ihn ja auch schon länger verfolgt habe, in anderen Vereinsfarben, dass er jetzt da nochmal wohl was gefunden hat, an dem er Spaß hat. Ja, und weil ich das so gesagt habe, mit diesem Max-Alegrifußball die Wochen davor, waren wirklich wieder schwer zu ertragen teilweise, was Milan gespielt hat. Ein Freund unseres und auch dieses Podcasts hier, Francesco, hat das Ganze, nachdem ich gemeint hatte, irgendwie Milan zu gucken, erraubt mir jegliche Energie, hat er gesagt, ich hätte den Begriff Dementorenfußball perfekt erklärt. Man muss dazu sagen, Francescos Juve-Fan, der hat viele Jahre mit Alegri verbracht, aber das ist manchmal wirklich, man guckt sich das an und denkt, wow, also das ist kein Tempo, das ist verwalten und irgendwie machst du das 1-0. Aber Milan ist seit 20 Spielen ungeschlagen und Alegri jetzt, das ist halt richtig stabil. Aber oft, gerade im Schlusstrittel, fehlten so die ein oder anderen Ideen. Alegri hat ja auch sein System insofern umgestellt, dass er jetzt in Raphael Leão nicht mehr Flügel, sondern er tatsächlich auch 2. Stürmer Doppelspitze im Kulissieg gegeben hat. Und im Spiel dagegen Lecce saß oft schon ein wenig besser aus, aber sie haben unfassbar viele Torschance vergeben. Und dann ist dieses Tor, das Füllkrug macht, wirklich auch so ein Classic-Neuner-Tor. Also Flanke kommt von der Grundlinie und erwämmst ihn irgendwie im Kopf, aber auch noch schön platziert neben den Pfosten rein. Ich glaube, das kann der Mannschaft sehr viel geben. Und sie sind ja auch immer noch im Meisterrennen gut mit dabei. Nur drei Zähler hinter Inter, die dann auch über wahrscheinlich noch eine längere Strecke in der Champions League Doppelbelastung haben werden. Also, es ist, glaube ich, gut möglich, dass wir noch im weiteren Verlauf dieser Saison, auch in diesem Podcast über Füllkrug und Milan sprechen können, wenn es dann auch vielleicht darum geht, die Meisterschaft da einzufahren.
Das ist so ein geiler Karriereweg, den er hat. Aber sag mal, wenn er Stammspieler werden würde– Verletzungen dürfen nicht sein, und er reicht so ein bisschen hin– aber wen würde er denn dann ersetzen? Pjulisic oder Leao? Oder müsste Allegri dann umstellen? Weil irgendwie, ich kann mir das gerade nicht vorstellen, dass er einen von beiden verdrängt.
Nee, kann ich auch nicht. Und ich glaube, das ist aber auch okay für ihn. Also vielleicht ist das auch für seinen Körper genau das Richtige. Meistens ist es dann so, dass wenn er reinkommt, dass sie dann eher wieder in so ein System abkippen, was da vorgespielt wurde. Also dann, wenn Leao drauf bleibt, geht er halt auf links und Pjulisic kommt dann ein bisschen mehr über rechts. In dem Fall, in dem Spiel ist Pjulisic rausgegangen, aber glaube ich auch, weil er ein bisschen auf dem Zahnfleisch ging und da die Körner gelassen hatte. Aber in den Partien davor war es tatsächlich so, dass sie dann– da lagen sie auch einmal zurück– dass sie dann eben mit drei Angreifern gespielt haben. Ich bin da eher bei dir. Also ich vermute nicht, dass Niklas Füllkrug ganz, ganz viele Spiele, gerade weil es ja auch nicht diese englischen Wochen für Milan mit Europapokal gibt, dass der ganz oft in der Startelf spielen wird. Und das wäre ja dann auch was. Du hast den Karriereweg angesprochen. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich einer, der kann trotz dieser Verletzungen, also Hannover Werder, dann noch England Nationalmannschaft, Milan. Freut mich wahnsinnig für ihn, aber ja, also, war er auch nicht immer nur bekannt dafür, so diese Feel-Good-Atmosphäre auszustrahlen. Das ist auch einer, der fordert und…
Hast du deswegen gerade den BVB unterschlagen bei seinem Karriereweg?
Oh, stimmt, ja. Müssen wir mal fragen, was ihm besser gefällt, Allegri-Fußball oder Kovac-Fußball? Genau, stimmt, ja, klar. Und wenn er jetzt aber sich da auch dann insofern weiterentwickelt, zu sagen, es ist okay für mich, irgendwie 20 Minuten zu kommen und dann noch mal in der ersten Aktion zwei Innenverteidiger umzuchecken und der Mannschaft zu helfen, dann wäre das ja auch eventuell genau die Rolle, die er in der Nationalmannschaft einnehmen könnte. Weil ich glaube, auch da, selbst bei hohem Fitnessgrad, wäre er wahrscheinlich kein Kandidat für die Startelf, unter Julian Nagelsmann, ohne mich da ist, tatsächlich so dezidiert miteinander auseinandergesetzt zu haben in den letzten Monaten.
Ja, ist ein guter Punkt. Ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Also ich muss sagen, so Meisterschaft Milan, alle Interfans verzeiht es mir bitte, und dann bitte nochmal so ein Video, so wie damals Ibrahimovic, als er die Ansprache gehalten hat, wir waren un-unugruppo und wir haben es geschafft und so weiter. Und das einfach in der Niklas Füllkrug-Variante, wahrscheinlich ein bisschen eine kürzere Rede, das würde mich anzünden, würde mich abholen.
Er hat ja schon für den einen oder anderen Schmunzler gesorgt, bei seiner Ankunft, als er nachts um 23 Uhr in Mainland gelandet ist. Und irgendwie, hey guys, bonjourno. Und man hört so was im Hintergrund. Ein Journalist, der sagt ja, bonassera.
Ja, aber gut, ich meine, warum sollte er anders sein, als jeder deutsche Tourist? Also, ist doch völlig okay. Erst mal zwei Expresse bestellen und dann geht es weiter.
Absolut.
Ach, Niklas Füllkrug, über den könnte man auch. Also, derjenige, der seine Biografie schreiben darf, in Zusammenarbeit mit ihm und dann noch ein paar Geschichten von ihm erzählt bekommt. Das wird ein glücklicher Mensch gewesen sein. Oder? Vielleicht ein Podcast draus machen? Niklas, meld dich. Aber gut, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Wir gehen in unsere Speed-Runde. Also jetzt noch mal ein bisschen schneller durch die Ligen hindurch. Wir schauen noch mal nach England, Chris. Und du hast uns heute so ein richtig schön aufeinander aufbauendes Gesamtsegment Premier League gebaut. Denn wir bleiben bei den Trainern. Du hast es ja vorhin schon kurz angedeutet. Genau.
Und noch eine Klarstellung. Ich habe schon gedacht, das ist an mir vorbei gegangen. Jermes ist natürlich Co-Trainer von Espirito Santo geworden.
Und ja, gut, dass ich auf den falschen Fuß auf mich fallen. Ich dachte ja tatsächlich schon, die KI hat mich ausgetrickst. Ich weiß noch, wie ich diese Fotos gesehen habe in diesem West Ham Trainingsjacke. Und ich bin dann extra noch auf die Suche gegangen, weil ich mir gedacht habe, naja, komm, das kann nicht sein. Und habe dann tatsächlich Referenzen gefunden, denen ich vertraut habe und dachte mir, scheiße, jetzt hat sie mich erwischt. Das erste Mal hat sie mich verarscht. Aber er ist auch nicht Trainer, er ist nur Co-Trainer. Aber er stand tatsächlich auch in der Seitenlieder. Also das habe ich auch Gott sei Dank richtig gesehen.
Also Fabian, falls du mal ein Bild siehst, wo Peter Neurora aus einem Porsche aussteigt und dahinter ist Real Madrid, das wäre dann auch KI-Photoshop. Ja, nicht mal KI.
Ach so, Photoshop. Okay, aber ich spiele jetzt erst mal beruhigt, okay.
So Chris, aber dein Thema.
Genau, genau. Dieser West Ham-Sieg bei Tottenham hat schon beinahe auch dort den nächsten Trainerwechsel ausgelöst, denn die Stimmung bei Tottenham drohte da endgültig zu kippen. Im Stadion wurde Sacked in the Morning gesungen, laute Buhrruf. Also es war schon somit die schlimmste Stimmung bei Tottenham seit Ewigkeiten, schlimmer als damals auch bei Espirito Santo bei Tottenham, also nicht verwirrt werden. Tottenham, da läuft es dieses Jahr gar nicht. Zu dem Zeitpunkt hat der Tottenham nur 2 Siege aus den letzten 13 Spielen geholt, 3 niederlagenden Folgesamt-FA-Cup aus. Der Trainerwechsel zu Thomas Frank lief bisher nicht so, wie erwünscht und jeder Umfeld ist frustriert. Trotzdem bekam Frank jetzt nochmal die Chance gegen den BVB und schien ja auch so, als ob er diese Chance genutzt hat. Die 1. Halbzeit war ziemlich gut, die beste Leistung seit Wochen. Dazu muss man aber auch sagen, Dortmund hat natürlich einen Platzweis bekommen, das schmiedert das Ganze ein bisschen. Und die 2. Halbzeit war auch schon wieder typisch Thomas Frank. Pragmatisch, ein bisschen uninspirierender Fußball. Und ja, also die Skepsis bleibt, Frank ist auch weiterhin unter Druck. Man muss dazu sagen, vieles liegt an ihm, keine Frage. Ich habe schon gesagt, sein Fußball ist nicht der beste. Und man muss dazu auch sagen, dass die Bedingungen nicht die besten sind, die Strategie des Clubs ist auch seit einigen Jahren schon so ein bisschen schwammig. Man hat Elite-Ticketpreise, Elite-Stadion, aber der Kader hinkt dem Ganzen so ein bisschen hinterher. Also man will, glaube ich, etwas sein, was man einfach noch nicht natürlich geworden ist. Und dementsprechend ist der Kader auch nicht ideal. Und trotzdem finde ich, dass das größte Problem von Thomas Frank ist, dass er eben nicht eigentlich Poste Cochleau ist. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich war nie der größte Poste Cochleau-Fan. Ich hielt seinen Fußball für etwas eindimensional. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man sich mal mehr diesen Kontrast betrachten. Für was stand der Poste Cochleau? Für sehr mutigen Fußball, Angriffsfußball, fast zu sehr zumutigen Fußball, Harakiri-Fußball. Und gleichzeitig war er auch ziemlich charismatisch, euphorisch, mit der Presse gut, hat auch die Fans einfach mobilisiert und an Bord gezogen. Und Frank ist so ein bisschen das Gegenteil. Also seine Kommunikation ist deutlich ruhiger, sachlicher, zurückhaltender, vorsichtig fast schon. Und sein Fußball ist ähnlich, sehr pragmatisch, kontrollierter, negativer. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass viele Fans, die einfach Poste Cochleau aufgrund seiner Art, seines Charisma so ins Herz geschlossen hatten, und er hat ihnen ja auch den Europa League-Titel beschert, muss man auch sagen, da hatte es jeder Nächste Trainer schwer. Und ich denke einfach auch, dass es Frank einfach wegen seines Wesens und seiner Art und Philosophie noch schwerer hatte. Dann kommt auch der Vorpaar dazu, dass er vor allem im Spiel mit einer Arsenal-Tasse gesehen würde, auf dem Platz. Das ist natürlich nicht gerade ideal.
Als sie nicht bei Arsenal gespielt haben, muss man dazu sagen. Genau, richtig. Ansonsten könnte man eher sagen, ja gut. Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen seltsam, oder?
Ja, das ist halt. Man hat auch früher immer gemerkt, dass Thomas Frank immer sehr von Arsenal geschwärmt hat. Also ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwelche Sympathien noch sind und die Tasse vielleicht noch im Schrank stand. Also ja, aber unterm Strich muss man sagen, ich halte Thomas Frank für einen sehr guten Trainer. Er hat einen super Job bei Brentford gemacht, allerdings auch in einem kleineren familiären Umfeld. Ich denke einfach unterm Strich muss man sagen, dass er womöglich der falsche Mann zur falschen Zeit am falschen Ort ist. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das bei Tottenham jetzt auch nicht mehr so lange gehen wird. Die Geduld, die der Klub hat, liegt vielleicht auch daher, dass aktuell kein Antonio Conte am Strand liegt und auf den Anruf wartet. Also, ohne in der Champions League läuft es ja auch gut, muss man dazu sagen. Also, da ist man ja in den Top 8. Aber ich denke, allzu lange wird das mit Thomas Fangen schmecken.
Also, in der Liga ist wirklich übel, Platz 14 mit 27 Punkten. Und dazu muss man sagen, im Februar wird es richtig hart. 1. Februar Manchester City, 7. Februar Manchester United, 10. Februar Newcastle, 22. Februar Arsenal. Also, das haut schon ganz schön rein. Da ist es nicht zu erwarten, dass sie damit 12 Punkten rausgehen aus diesen vier Spielen. Ja, das ist ja Teil des Brustes der BVB-Fans zu Recht auch, dass man bei diesem Tottenham, bei diesen Spurs, so eine erste Hälfte gespielt hat und in der zweiten Hälfte im Unterzahl er letztlich gezeigt hat, was möglich gewesen wäre. Aber ja, es sollte nicht sein. Dann blicken wir mal weiter in La Liga. Fabian, über was ist denn da noch zu sprechen? Ich habe es vorhin schon so ein bisschen angeteased.
Ja, ich bleibe heute königlich und komme von den Königlichen aus Madrid zur Königlichen Gesellschaft aus San Sebastian im Baskenland. Die haben nämlich einen sehr überraschenden Schachzug Ende des Jahres, vergangenen Jahres gemacht, nämlich sie haben mit einem neuen Trainer verpflichtet, der keinen Stallgeruch hat. Normalerweise setzen die Basken ja sehr auf Eigengewächse in den letzten Jahren. Und sie haben mit Pellegrino Matarazzo einen Trainer geholt, den viele von uns wahrscheinlich noch kennen aus seiner Bundesliga-Zeit Hoffenheim, Stuttgart. Dann war er aber lange weg, zumindest habe ich ihn überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Schirm gehabt und dann hat er plötzlich bei Real Sociedad San Sebastian unterschrieben. Ein Club, bei dem es stark gekrieselt hat, seit Immanuel Aguasil den Verein verlassen hat. Sie haben es dann wieder mit einem eigenen Trainer versucht, also der der zweiten Mannschaft, der so hochgezogen worden hat, nicht funktioniert. Die sind weit unten in der Liga rumgekrebst, haben aber rein kadermäßig und infrastrukturmäßig natürlich höhere Ambitionen. Und Matarazzo hat tatsächlich aus seinen ersten drei Pflichtspielen zwei Siege und einen Unentschieden geholt, ist im Pokal weitergekommen gegen Osasuna, nachdem man da schon 0-2 zurück lag, hat in Chitapec gewonnen mit 2 zu 1, hat Unentschieden gespielt gegen Atletico Madrid und hat zu Hause jetzt Barca geschlagen mit 2 zu 1. War zwar viel Dusel dabei, hatte ich vorher schon angekündigt, weil Barca hätte eigentlich auch 5-6 Tore machen müssen können. Haben sie ja teilweise auch wurden dann aber aberkannt. Aber Dusel muss man sich irgendwo auch erarbeiten. Und deswegen ist dieser Einstand, muss ich sagen, tatsächlich sehr geglückt. Sie haben sich in der Liga ordentlich jetzt nach vorne gearbeitet. Und ja, eine sehr interessante Verpflichtung, wie ich finde, völlig unerwartet und scheint aber zu funktionieren. Und finde ich eine ganz gute Geschichte für den Trainer, der ja, glaube ich, US-Amerikaner ist, aber dann doch in Deutschland irgendwie aufgewachsen ist und dadurch ausgebildet worden ist mit Nagelsmann zusammen und so weiter. Und der jetzt La Liga bereichert.
Und spielt er denn auch so einen Ballbesitzansatz, wie wir es beim VfB und bei der TSG gesehen haben?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall im Vergleich zu vorher deutlich offensiver geworden und auch intensiver, was das Pressing anbelangt. Schnelles Umschaltspiel, also ja, da hat er schon viel mitgenommen. Und die Defensive von San Sebastian war sehr anfällig vor allen Dingen. Das hat er dadurch jetzt aber stabilisieren können, weil die Mannschaft jetzt einfach mehr Druck nach vorne macht und dementsprechend natürlich auch die Defensive entlastet ist. Und das tut dem Klub ganz gut. Ich habe da auch einen 19-Jährigen, der gerade hinten in der Innenverteidigung steht, einen Talent. Das ist natürlich nicht so ganz einfach. Und wenn du natürlich den Ball eher hast bzw. eher den Weg nach vorne suchst, dann entlastet das eine Defensive. Und wie gesagt, die Ergebnisse im Moment sprechen ja tatsächlich für ihn.
Und das war, also ich glaube, alle haben, oder wer es mitbekommen hat, dass Matarazzo der Trainer ist, der hat es wahrscheinlich ähnlich mitbekommen wie ich, nämlich nach dem Sieg über Hansi Flick und dann den herumgehenden Beams in wirklich Fußball-Nerd-Kreisen, dass man dann gemeint hat, ah, okay, alles klar. Ja, schauen wir, wie es weitergeht für Real Sociedad. Jetzt dann gegen Celta Vico, Athletic Bebau und dann geht es ja ins Viertelfinale der Copa del Rey. Könnte schon sein, dass er da was aufbauen kann. Bin ich sehr gespannt darauf. Dann blicken wir nochmal in die Eredivisie, Daniel. Was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, ich hatte ja vor vergangenes Jahr hier im Rasenfunk schön gesagt, na ja, ich glaube, Veynord, die wäre sicher meister. Und ich glaube, das war eine der größten Fehlprognosen in den letzten Jahrtausenden. Also aktuell ist PSV auf 1 mit 16 Punkten Vorschwung vor Veynord. Und naja, gut, es hat sich noch ein bisschen gewandelt. Und ich glaube, die andere große Fehlprognose hängt bei mir im Schrank. Das ist ein Werder-Trikot mit Flock-Navigator. Das ist die andere große Fehlprognose.
Warum haben wir jemals auf dich gehört? Hätte mir das gewusst.
In dem Punkt, naja, gut. Also immer gucken, was größer ist. Aber es kommt relativ nah dran, beide Sachen.
Warte mal ganz kurz. Denkst du, Clemens Fritz ist ein guter Sportdirektor?
Ich möchte mich nicht außerteilen. Vielleicht. Ich leihe erst mal wen aus.
Okay, ich dachte, du gibst noch eine Prognose.
Nein, ich hab nichts zurück. Aber ich kann versuchen zu erklären, wie ich zu diesem Tuchschluss kam. Ich glaube, wie sehr viele auch in der Divisi. Ich hab mich ein bisschen blenden lassen von der Art und Weise, wie Robin van Persie's Taktik bei Feyenoord so gut funktioniert hat. Also, wir hatten jetzt schon den Dementorenfußball in Italien. Das ist so ein bisschen Wildwestfußball in unserem westlichen Nachbarland. Also, van Persie spielt wirklich teilweise echt sehr, sehr offensiv im Fußball, geht voll drauf, versucht echt hohes Gegenpressing und hat eigentlich so ein Grundsystem, so ein 4-3-3. Im Ballbesitz, im Angriff ist es teilweise ein 3-1-6. Also, wenn man durchzählt, findet man wirklich acht Spieler, teilweise im und um gegnerischen Sechzehner. Das ist wirklich, wirklich krass. Hat, wenn es funktioniert, die Folge, dass du natürlich ständig einen Druck hast auf den Gegner. Du hast die ganzen zweiten Bälle, die gewonnen werden. Du hast permanent echt ein aggressives Positionssystem. Die Gefahr ist, wenn es schief geht. Hast du halt hinten große Räume und dann hast du schnell Konter-Situationen. Jetzt hatten sie ein sehr wildes Spiel am Wochenende. Dann haben sie verloren auch ein 4-3 gegen Sparta, wo sie am Ende beim 3-3 auf sie gespielt haben, waren auch wieder mit 8 Mann vorne. Und dann gab es ein, zwei lange Pässe und da hatten sie eine 4-2-Situation gegen sich. Die haben sie dann auch zum Tor geführt. Diese Art von Spiel hat in den ersten Spielen herausragend funktioniert. Da hatten sie mit die wenigsten Gegentrohre trotz dieser Spielweise in der Liga. Weil da die Identität gestimmt hat, die Abstimmung gestimmt hat, und da haben viele gesagt– eilglich nicht mehr –,Dass wenn sie das durchhalten, sie gute Chancen haben, weil PSV so inkonstant war zu Beginn der Saison und Feyenoord eben nicht. Das Problem ist, dass sich das Ganze, das Überladen der Abwahrreihe und dieses aggressive Spiel, so langsam von einigen Mannschaften dekodiert wurde, so ein bisschen. Sie haben in der Anfangsphase die Gegner von Feyenoord oft versucht, sich rauszuspielen und versuchen, da so ein bisschen durchzukommen. Es hat aber nicht funktioniert. Es war ja auch so ein bisschen dieses Lockmittel von Van Klaassen, das sie mit der Gegner einladen will, es mit Kurzpass zu versuchen. Diese langen Bälle eben nicht verspielt. Die kommen jetzt vermehrt. Da zeigt dann doch dieses System auf Dauer, auf Langstrecke, so ein bisschen Schwächen. Das hat dazu geführt, dass dann Feyenoord etwas inkonstanter wurde und da hier mal ein Punkt liegen gelassen hat. Und bei Eintrufen, die haben sich im Gegenzug relativ schnell, relativ konstant stabilisiert, weil sie auch einfach ein bisschen Glück haben. Die haben ja auch einige Ausfälle. Der Player, den es auf Gladbach fehlt, ist immer noch verletzt. Das hatten sie jetzt bei dem Afrika-Cup Saibari, der jetzt nicht so viel Umstand, auch recht lange nicht, weil er im Finale mit Marco war. Da haben sie aber das Glück, dass sie just in dem Moment, wo man Saibari, ein wichtiger Kreativspieler, nicht mehr spielen konnte für Pace Way, Paul Wanner eingeschlagen ist. Der hatte einen sehr schnellen Stand zu Beginn, kam nicht zum Zug und jetzt konnte er die Chance nutzen bei Pace Way und macht jetzt seine Tore und ist ein wichtiger Faktor geworden im Mittelfeld. Da haben sie auch ein bisschen Glück. Und als letzten Grund noch– es klingt immer so, wie eine Ausrede– aber die Verletzungsbeserre bei Feenord ist auch schon echt gewaltig. Die haben Jakob Moda im Mittelfeld, fällt seit August eigentlich schon schon aus. Die haben in der Defensive den Trauner, der ausfällt. Die haben den Theorit, der bei Bayern immer mal wieder in der Gerüchteküche auftaucht. Der fällt jetzt bis März noch aus. Ueda im Sturm, der relativ wichtig ist für die Offensive, ist jetzt auch angeschlagen derzeit im Spiel gegen Sparta. Da haben sie jetzt Hans-Musa erwischt, mal gucken, wie schlimm es bei denen ist. Also es sind nur einige. Das spielt dann in der Masse auch, glaube ich, eine Rolle mit dem Traun. Und ja, jetzt ist für jetzt für eben 16 Punkte Vorsprung. Und wie sagt man so? Ich glaube, jetzt werden die Meister. Ich wechsle mal die Fahne. Ich lasse die mal aus, meine Fahne im Wind.
Oh je, das Urteil ist gesprochen. Feyenoord holt wieder auf. Aber dann wird es wenigstens spannend. Sehr schön, Daniel. Und du warst ja dessen ja auch schon bewusst, dass du am 2. Oktober eine Frühprognose abgegeben hast, dass du dich da weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt hast. Aber das darf ja auch mal sein. Und gerade die Verletzung in der Innenverteidigung, auch Thomas Beelen fehlt ja glaube ich auch schon die ganze Saison über. Und der hat in der Vorsaison schon Stamm gespielt, glaube ich. Und gerade wenn wir über so Restverteidigungsthemen sprechen, da macht es dann doch wahrscheinlich einen Unterschied, ob die individuelle Qualität die höchste ist, die du gerade im Kader hast oder halt nur ganz weit höchste.
Aber es macht auch gerade deswegen sehr viel Spaß, Fan-Nords zu schauen aktuell. Es hat zum Beispiel den Sohn von Van Persie, der spielt jetzt auch. Und der hat jetzt bei dem Vierterei hat er gleich mal einen rausgehauen, nämlich ein Hackentor und ein Fallrückzieher-Tor. Zum 2-3 und 3-3. Hat dann in der nicht gereicht, aber da sieht man auf jeden Fall schon, da ist auch Talent vorhanden.
Und das war ein schöner Fallrückzieher.
Vor allem, und der hat auch den Papa-Ni-Slide perfektioniert, bei diesem einen Jubel. Der hat mich sofort an den Papa erinnert, wie er da gerutscht ist.
Ach, ich sehe schon. Also diese Nachwuchs-Väter-Eltern-Mütter-Folge, irgendwann müssen wir sie doch noch machen. Sie drängt sich ja geradezu auf. Aber Mario, wenn du jetzt eh dein Mikro offen hast, wir haben jetzt gerade über jemanden gesprochen, der hat abreißen lassen, wollen wir dann jetzt über jemanden sprechen, den der Serie A hat abreißen lassen in der Tabelle.
Können wir gerne machen. Der Name wurde ja auch gerade schon mal getroppt. Der liegt nämlich nicht am Strand, sondern der macht sich und seine Mannschaft Mürbe. Antonio Conte. Und ich bin ja Fan davon, wenn man mit irgendwelchen Hot-Tags aufräumt, die man mal gemacht hat, wo man daneben lag. Hab ich glaube ich zwar nicht hier gemacht, aber ich habe mich irgendwo mal dazu hinreißen lassen, zu sagen, dass ich glaube, dass das vielleicht die erste Saison wird, in der Antonio Conte nicht nur Liga kann, sondern auch Champions League. Und jetzt lassen sie zum einen in der Liga abreißen, aber auch in der Champions League stehen sie knapp unterm Strich von den Playoffs, was ja in diesem Ligasystem, das da gespielt wird, finde ich schon ganz schön harte Nummer ist für den amtierenden Meister. Und ja, die Probleme bei Napoli, die fangen früh an. Also wenn man zu Hause 0-0 gegen Eintracht Frankfurt spielt, glaube ich, weiß man so ein bisschen, wo das Problem ist. Sie sind zu ungefährlich im Sturm. Sie haben zu wenig Spieler, die treffen. In der Champions League haben tatsächlich nur Rasmus Heul und Scott McTominay Tore geschossen dieses Jahr für die SSC. Und das, was Daniel gerade auch gesagt hat, ist, das muss man ihm vielleicht irgendwie so zu Gute halten. Wir haben auch unfassbar viele Verletzten. Also ging ja los mit Kevin de Bruyne, aber jetzt in den letzten Wochen fehlt ständig in einem Mannschaftsteil eine tragende Säule, ob es jetzt wieder in der Innenverteidigung Rachmani war, der da wegbricht, ob die Flügelzange erst Neresch sich verletzt, jetzt auch noch Politano, wo dann auch Antonio Conte auf einmal mit Nachwuchsspielern in der Champions League auflaufen muss, was er wirklich, ich glaube, da muss der überredet werden. Vielleicht früher hätte er zu Zehnt gespielt, bevor er noch irgendeinen Jugendspieler einwechselt, so und jetzt hat er auf einmal noch mal vier auf der Bank. Das ist schon ein bisschen besorgniserregend, vor allem, weil ich mich noch bis vor vier Wochen über so einen richtigen Dreikampf auch in der Meisterschaft gefreut hatte. Jetzt haben sie zwar auch neun Spiele nicht verloren, allerdings innerhalb der letzten fünf Partien waren vier Remis mit dabei, unter anderem auch gegen Abstiegskandidaten wie Hellas, Verona und Palma, 0-0 gegen Palma, die davor auch wirklich in jedem Spiel immer gegen Tore gefressen haben und eine wirklich unstabile Abwehr haben. Das ist echt ein wenig ernüchternd, vor allem wenn man sich so ein bisschen drauf gefreut hat, dass sich da hinter Milan und Napoli battlen. Und in der Champions League, wie gesagt, da sind acht Punkte gleichauf mit Kopenhagen gegen, die sie jetzt da gespielt haben. Und am letzten Spieltag hat man ein Heimspiel gegen Chelsea, die jetzt nach dem, ich glaube auch nicht so wirklich überzeugenden, aber Sieg gegen Parvus immer noch die Möglichkeit hätten, unter die Top 8 zu kommen. Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht irgendwie, dass die nach Süditalien fahren und sagen, da lassen wir ein bisschen auslaufen. Und gerade wenn man sich das anguckt, wie intensiv diese Art Fußball spielen zu lassen von Konte ist, glaube ich, sowohl körperlich als auch mental. Vielleicht tut es ihnen sogar gut, gar nicht weiterzukommen in der Champions League, aber das kann halt nicht ihr Anspruch sein. Auch monetär gesehen, was sich da ist, wieder in diesen Kader gesteckt haben. Und da ist er dann auch wieder derjenige gewesen. Erst waren es ihm zu wenig Neuzugänge, dann waren es ihm zu viele, weil wir sollen sie alle integrieren. Jetzt sind es natürlich wieder zu wenige, weil er ist dann, also das ist auch wieder Antonio Konte, Masterclass auf jeder Pressekonferenz. Das ist höchst unterhaltsam, wenn man halt irgendwie nicht ganz so mit dem Herzen an dem Verein dranhängt. Und ich glaube aber für die Tifosi da schon sehr, sehr schwer. Und sie haben halt auch ein paar richtige Ruhrkrepierer geholt. Ich glaube, Chris Lorenzo Luca soll ja irgendwie in die Premier League verschifft werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob da der Verein, der ihn dann holt, Spaß dran hat. Der läuft rum wie Falschgeld. Das wäre eigentlich noch mal so einer, den sie da vorne irgendwie als Stürmer gehabt hätten, der ihnen dann mal was wegnipst. Aber bei dem funktioniert überhaupt gar nichts. Und ja, weil PSV gerade Thema war, ich habe die sind auch einmal komplett drübergerollt über Napoli. Freue ich mich aber sehr drauf, Daniel, melde ich mich nächste Woche mal bei dir. Da darf ich nämlich nach Eindhoven. Da werde ich noch die eine oder andere Frage zu Peter Boss Fußball. Genau, also das ist bei Napoli gerade so der Stand der Dinge. Es kommt jetzt immerhin Lukaku zurück. Der saß jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Mal auf der Bank. Der bekommt wohl dann demnächst die eine oder andere Spielminute mehr. Der war ja auch in der Meistersaison so mit der Schlüsselspieler für Antonio Konter, auch wenn Scott McTominay alles überragt hat.
Also schauen wir mal. Ich meine, es sind nur sechs Punkte auf Inter, drei auf Milan. Die wird man auch noch spielen, irgendwann im Frühjahr dann. Aber ja, der Trend ist wirklich schlecht. Ich habe das Kopenhagenspiel nur in der Konferenz gesehen. Aber da hat man sich jetzt nicht eine Tutechips-Vorbegeisterung aufgemacht.
Na, vor allem, sie spielen in Überzahl, gehen in Führung und spielen dann noch irgendwie über eine Halbzeit eben gegen Zehn und kriegen trotzdem kaum Torschancen kreiert und fangen sich dann so ein dummes Elfmeter gegen Tor. Hätten sich danach schon von der Standardsituation fast den Ausgleich gefressen. Das spricht, glaube ich, dafür auch, wenn ich sage, so diese mentalen Anforderungen, die Antonio Conte an seinem Team hat. Die Mannschaft wirkt sehr müde und ja irgendwie befangen.
Da liegt so ein bisschen Mehlstaub drauf, Mehltau heißt es, glaube ich. Na ja, also Napoli lässt abreißen. Dann blicken wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Jakob, du hast uns ein wunderschönes, also du hast es hier überschrieben mit das nächste Kapitel in der wunderbaren Welt des Multiclub-Ownership. Da habe ich ja schon wieder so richtig Bock drauf. Was ist jetzt schon wieder los?
Ja, wie kann man denn eine Rasenfunk-Folge Ligatour international machen, ohne mindestens einmal über Multiclub-Ownership zu sprechen? Und welch schöneres Beispiel könnte man sich da aussuchen, als über Racing-Club Strasbourg zu sprechen? Die– es ist ja so ein bisschen verknüpft mit einem der Themen, über das Chris auch vorhin schon gesprochen hat, denn es geht ja um den Trainerwechsel bei Strasbourg. Zu Saisonbeginn war es ja noch der Kapitän, der dann mitten während der Saison mit einem Chelsea-Trikot posiert hat und sich so gefreut hat auf seinen anstehenden Sommerwechsel nach den harten Verhandlungen zwischen den beiden Vereinen. Und dann war es jetzt in der Winterpause, oder Winterpause in Anführungsstrichen, der Trainer von Strasbourg, der dann ja plötzlich auf der einen PK noch gar nichts davon wusste, dass er überraschenderweise Nachfolgekandidat von Enzo Maresca sein sollte und dann ein paar Tage später aber logischerweise doch weg war. Also Liam Mourinho ist nicht mehr Trainer bei Strasbourg. Er ist zu Chelsea gewechselt und ja, ich glaube, das Echo bei den Fans und den Supportergruppen von Strasbourg kann sich jeder von uns vorstellen. Und ich glaube auch jeder von uns kann das Gefühl nachvollziehen, wie man sich fühlt, wenn der Trainer einfach so mitten während der Saison geht und einem einfach ja klar und deutlich vor Augen geführt wird. Dieser Verein ist eine B-Mannschaft und hier wird– ich meine, es ist ja– warum ist man Fußballfan? Man ist Fußballfan, weil man– auch wenn jeder weiß, dass es inzwischen sehr, sehr klein ist, dass man die Hoffnung hat, dass ja zumindest theoretisch maximaler Erfolg möglich wäre und dieser Illusion wird man halt komplett beraubt, wenn man merkt, okay, es gibt einfach innerhalb des eigenen Vereins Personen, denen ist der Erfolg der eigenen Mannschaft nicht wichtig oder sogar egal oder er ist sogar kontraproduktiv. Weil es gibt dann ja immer noch die Frage, was würde eigentlich passieren, wenn die beiden in der Champions League sich qualifizieren würden? Dann könnte ja– soweit ich die Regularien der UEFA verstanden habe– wenn man nicht es schafft, eins der Schlupflöcher zu nehmen, würde sich dann ja das Team qualifizieren, was in der Tabelle höher steht. Nehmen wir an, Straßburg wäre dritter, Chelsea vierter. Dann wäre das für die Vereinsbesitzer echt beschissen.
Das wird nicht passieren, dass dann Chelsea nicht steht. Die müssen ihre Anteile am Verein in einen Treuhandfonds geben für die Zeit, in der der Wettbewerb läuft. Und das muss man aber bis zum 1. März angemeldet oder vorbereitet haben. Das war ja das Problem zwischen mit Lyon und Crystal Palace.
Aber trotzdem ist es halt so, okay, wir die Straßburg-Fans haben jetzt nochmal vor Augen geführt bekommen, dass es einfach nicht im Interesse ihrer Besitzer ist, dass sie jetzt den maximal größten Erfolg haben. Zumindest solange man denkt, okay, der Chelsea braucht irgendwas aus diesem Verein, dann wird Chelsea das auch bekommen. Und ich glaube, dieser Konsequenz ist wirklich sehr, sehr bitter. Es gibt vor jedem Spiel eine 15-Minuten-Protestphase, wo es keinen Support gibt von den Fans, jetzt auch seit Monaten schon. Aber ich weiß nicht so wirklich, ob da ein Ende in Sicht ist. Chris wollte zwischendurch was sagen.
Genau, als du die Proteste angemerkt hast. Ich muss dazu sagen, das ist natürlich ein anderes Level, wenn du der B-Club dieses Konsortiums bist. Das ist ja nochmal viel frustrierender, viel schlimmer für die Fans zu ertragen und alle Beteiligten. Aber es ist nur ganz interessant zu erwähnen, dass auch bei Chelsea aktuell oder zuletzt es Proteste gab, eben wegen diesem Modell von Bluko, also der Gruppe quasi, weil das ist ja auch nicht im Interesse der Fans, dass eine Mannschaft so eine Mannschaft da ist, um Investitionen voranzubreiben und Gewinne zu erzielen, sondern man will Titel gewinnen. Und das sorgt auch bei Chelsea Fans für Frust, natürlich auf einem anderen Level. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, dieses Konstrukt, was da geschaffen wurde, sorgt auch bei den Nutzniezern davon, bei der nutzniezenden Mannschaft, ebenfalls für Frust.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es halt schon auch ein Problem ist, wenn der sportliche Erfolg dann nicht so richtig sich einstellt. Zumindest, ich sage mal so, wäre Chelsea jetzt weiter in einem Meisterschaftskampf, wäre der Unmut gerade von Seiten Chelsea sicherlich geringer. Aber auch bei Straßburg würde es zumindest etwas mehr die Probleme kaschieren können, nicht unbedingt so dauerhaft, aber zumindest kurzfristig hat das ja beispielsweise in der letzten Saison schon ganz gut funktioniert, weil man da ja das erste Mal seit längerem wieder wirklich auch oben mitspielen konnte. Und jetzt in dieser Saison, man spielt ja auch keine Katastrophenrunde, aber man steht halt auch in der Liga nur auf Platz 7, hat den Kontakt an die Champions League-Ränge ein bisschen verloren. Und was dann noch dazu kommt, die Leihspieler, die man von Chelsea hat, funktionieren eigentlich nicht gut. Also Kendri Páez spielt fast gar nicht. Der Keeper Mike Pendas macht es ganz gut, aber jetzt auch nicht viel besser oder eigentlich sogar ein bisschen schlechter als Petrovic, den man letzte Saison von Chelsea ausgeliehen hatte im Tor. Also hat man sozusagen da auch noch mal ein Downgrade bekommen. Mamadou Sarr in der Innenverteidigung, ja, den hatte man vorher eh schon. Deswegen ist auch da so der Faktor, okay, das ist jetzt ein Spieler, den wir vielleicht sonst nicht gekriegt hätten, nicht so gut, auch wenn der ganz okaye Leistungen zeigt. Aber es funktioniert halt nix. Emmanuel Mega, der Kapitän und eigentlich ja auch Star und Leistungsträger des Teams, spielt gar nicht, ist fast die ganze Saison verletzt, wechselt dann im Sommer zu Chelsea, wo, glaube ich, alle eigentlich ganz froh drüber sind, weil er sich auch abseits des Platzes nicht so sonderlich beliebt gemacht hat. Er hat nämlich auch in einem Interview zum Beispiel erzählt, dass, bevor er nach Straßburg gewechselt sei, die meisten Fans oder die meisten, die sich nicht so mit dem französischen Fußball beschäftigen, gedacht hätten, dass Straßburg eine Stadt in Deutschland gewesen wäre. Also, glaube ich, auch eine Äußerung, die sicherlich bei der Lokalbemerkung…
Als nächstes gesagt, dass Elsas könnten wir doch auch wieder abgeben. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Ja, okay.
Also da bemüht sich jemand auf jeden Fall, alle Brücken einzureißen auf dem Weg nach London. Ja, und dementsprechend ist die Stimmung in Straßburg nicht gut, obwohl man zum Beispiel in der Conference League auch immerhin auf dem ersten Platz die Tabelle abgeschlossen hat. Also da auch vielleicht sogar noch ein Titel holen könnte. Auch im Pokal jetzt durch das Aus von PSG ist ja einiges möglich. Aber ja, die Fans sind ziemlich desillusioniert.
Verständlich. Und das Schlimme ist bei diesem Multi-Club-Ownership, wir müssen das Thema nicht wieder zum 1000. Mal aufmachen, aber der sportliche Erfolg, also Titel, das ist für die Eigentümer dieser Vereine eher so das Zubrot. Also nur wenn du es quasi aus Sportswashing-Gründen her machst, dann willst du halt auch mal die Champions League gewinnen, weil das quasi der hellste Stern ist, der strahlen kann im Fußball. Wenn du es aber machst, um Geld zu verdienen aus dem laufenden Betrieb, dann musst du einfach nur in der ersten Liga bleiben. Klar, möglichst gut, aber es geht über das TV-Geld und es geht über das Premier League-TV-Geld, alles andere ist völlig egal. Und das macht es ja nochmal so mehr frustrierend, dass man sich denkt, ja gut, für die Blue-Co macht jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so den riesen Unterschied, ob Chelsea jetzt 8. oder 7. oder 6. oder 5. oder 4. wird. Nur wenn sie wirklich den Titel haben wollen würden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann würde es einen riesen Unterschied machen. Das heißt, das Grundprinzip des Sports wird auch ein bisschen ausgehebelt. Naja, so, jetzt habe ich gute Laune. Wollen wir dann nochmal in die Premier League gucken?
Kann ich der Vollständigkeit halber noch kurz erwähnen, wer jetzt neuer Trainer ist bei Straßburg. Das habe ich nämlich jetzt ganz vergessen. Da hat dann nämlich auch die Wahl des neuen Trainers jetzt nicht gerade für Enthusiasmus gesorgt, denn es ist mit Gary O'Neill, ein Trainer aus England, gekommen, der jetzt auch bei Wolverhampton Wanderers und– wo war er noch? bei Bournemouth jetzt nicht so unbedingt für riesige Begeisterung gesorgt hat. Und ich glaube auch, das ist jetzt kein neuer Trainer, der einen träumen lässt in Straßburg, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen würde, das ist die schlimmste Wahl, die man hätte treffen können. Aber man hat mit ihm jetzt auch immerhin in seinem ersten Spiel den ersten Ligasieg seit dem 9. November geholt. Also mal schauen. Vielleicht kann er ja die Erwartungen so ein bisschen widerlegen und dann doch für ganz gute Stimmung sorgen, zumindest auf dem Platz.
Also ich kann nur zumindest für alle, die es gerade nicht im Video gesehen haben, der Gesichtsausdruck von Chris, das war eher so, dass das Emoji mit den hängenden Mundwinkeln, würde ich jetzt sagen, bei der Erwähnung von Gary O'Neill. Aber gut, Chris, was hast du uns denn aus England noch mitgebracht?
Ja, noch einen kurzen Blick zu Per Mertesacker, der nach sieben Jahren als Nachwuchsleiter Schluss gemacht hat, beziehungsweise zum Saisonende geht. Und ich dachte, es lohnt sich gleich mal drauf zu blicken, wie man ihn bei Arsenal in Erinnerung behalten wird für seine Arbeit. Auf dem Platz und neben dem Platz. Er war jetzt 15 Jahre bei Arsenal, das vergisst man schnell. Ziemlich lange Zeit. Und man hält auch sehr, sehr große Stücke auf ihn bei Arsenal. Und gerade in der Nachwuchsabteilung, was er dort geleistet hat, ist vielleicht, wenn wir jetzt gerade von diesen unschönen Aspekten des Fußballs oder des Geschäfts sprechen, war Mertesacker großer Initiator in einer gewissen Philosophie. Die Strong Young Gunners hieß das und oder heißt das. Da war er der Initiator. Und das diente dazu, den jungen Leuten, Spielern, Menschen, soll man da in der Stelle vielleicht auch betonen, wichtige Werte zu vermitteln wie Respekt, Disziplin, Bodenständigkeit. Hat auch viel für Mental Health gemacht, weil eben das Geschäft schwierig ist, gerade für junge Spieler oder heranreifende Spieler. Und er hat das immer sehr in den Vordergrund gestellt. Auch hat er oft betont, dass gerade die Fälle ihm sehr nah gehen, wenn er einfach Spielern oder Jugendlichen sagen muss, das reicht wahrscheinlich nicht. Und da war er immer so eine ganz wichtige Person bei Arsenal. Und dazu muss man auch sagen, natürlich unfassbar talentierte Spieler durch die Reihen gekommen. Bukai Osaka natürlich als Erstes zu nennen. Van Eyri, der jetzt noch Marcel verliehen würde, hat auch unfassbar viel Potenzial. Dann kommt auch schon die nächste Reihe mit Max Daumann und Marley Salmon. Wir werden wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Jahren mehr davon hören. Also viel, viel verletzt talent. Und dazu muss man auch sagen, all diese Spieler auch sehr, sehr bodenständig. Also gerade weil ich das mit dieser Philosophie genannt habe, dass man merkt auch, dass das wirkt. Denn so ein Bukai Osaka, da hast du ja keine Skandale als Beispiel. Also es sind alles sehr ruhige, bodenständige Typen, sehr sympathische Typen. Und das fruchtet. Ja, gleichzeitig ist wahrscheinlich auch Arsenal bereit für etwas Neues. Nicht, weil man nicht zufrieden war, im Gegenteil. Aber man merkt auch, dass Mertesackers Fokus auf die erste Mannschaft war. Einfach Talent in die erste Mannschaft zu führen. Und eben natürlich diese wichtigen Aspekte, die ich gerade nannte. Gleichzeitig musst du als Verein oder Top-Verein in England, die Academy auch ein Stück weit als Einnahmequelle sehen, so unschön das ist. Oder das legen viele so aus, wenn du siehst, was Chelsea oder City mit Talenten an Geld verdient, die es nicht bei City schafften. Aber gut genug für andere Vereine sind. Da hängt Arsenal ein gutes Stück hinterher. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man das jetzt auch als Chance sieht, einfach die Academy dahingehend zu nutzen, dass man hier auch ein bisschen Einnahmen generiert in Zeiten der finanziellen Zwänge, die man auch in der Premier League hat.
Come to Werder, Per.
Ja, weiß man denn, was er machen will?
Ja, gab es jetzt schon ein paar Gerüchte. Es hieß, er möchte erst mal eine kleine Auszeit nehmen oder eine kurze Auszeit nehmen.
Also bis zum Saisonende. Achso, nee, er arbeitet dann noch so lange.
Also es wurde auch schon von einem Jahr geredet, mal sehen. Es waren jetzt nur Gerüchte. Es gab auch Gerüchte an einem Posten beim DFB, kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen bei ihm. Ja, aber er scheint auf jeden Fall etwas Neues machen zu wollen und da können wir gespannt sein. Wer weiß.
Ich bin auch herhörig geworden bei der Aussage, wo du gesagt hast, wenn er Spielern gut vermittelt, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht reicht. Ich weiß, ich kann das auch bei Spielern aus der ersten Mannschaft machen.
Bezieht sich noch auf das Come-to-Werder, habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck. Aber das wäre schon richtig cool, irgendwie Thomas Bräuch, Nachwuchsleistungszentrumsleiter beim BVB per Mertesacker bei Werder. Also irgendwann können wir uns dann nur noch mit den Nachwuchsspielern beschäftigen. Ja, vielleicht will er in seiner Auszeit ein Tribüngespräch machen. Kann mir jemand Kontakt herstellen? Meldet euch bei mir. Mal gucken. Also, per Mertesacker, weg bei Arsenal am Ende dieser Saison. 15 Jahre, ey, das ist schon wirklich krass. Hätte mich raten lassen, da merkt man, wie alt man ist, ehrlicherweise.
Zusammen mit Atetta auf dem Platz gestanden, ne? Auch witzig, ja.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Stimmt. Richtig. Ja, unglaublich. Also, das ist die Premier League gewesen für diese Woche. Fabian, was hast du denn noch mitgebracht aus La Liga?
Ich habe dir was mitgebracht, was dich jetzt kurz ärgern wird, aber dann habe ich eine tolle Feel-Good-Geschichte dazu. Also, es geht leider wieder um Multiclub-Ownership, um dieses Thema. Es geht um den FC Girona aus Spanien. Der gehört ja zur City Group und da spielen auch die ein oder andere Spieler von Manchester City. Und die haben jetzt Marc-André ter Stegen verpflichtet, bis zu so einer Ausgabe. Und da kommt jetzt gleich meine Feel-Good-Geschichte dazu. Denn ihr kennt alle noch Juan Arango, Bundesliga-Legende, Borussia Mönchengladbach. Und mit wem hat er zusammengespielt bei Gladbach? Marc-André ter Stegen. Und mit wem spielt Marc-André ter Stegen jetzt in Chirona zusammen? Juan Arango. Aber es ist der Sohn von Juan Arango, der übrigens genauso aussieht.
Also es ist wirklich... Hat er auch so eine linke Klebe wie sein Vater.
So viel spielt er noch nicht. Also ich habe ihn noch nicht spielen sehen. Ich habe das auch erst vor kurzem erfahren. Es ist ein junges Talent, er ist noch relativ jung und hat noch nicht so viel Spielzeit, aber er sieht wirklich fast genauso aus. Es ist wirklich geil. Die beiden, wenn man sich so das Foto anschaut, Ters Degen mit Arango Alt und Ters Degen mit Arango Jung, das passt auf jeden Fall. Und das hat mich sehr gefreut, diese Geschichte. Und auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich jetzt die Frage, Ters Degen, Chirona, wird das reichen, um auf den WM-Zug aufzuspringen oder nicht? Chirona hat einen schlechten Saisonstart gehabt, ist jetzt so im Mittelfeld, ist gerade, ja fängt sich gerade, hat natürlich schon Qualität im Kader, weil finanzielle Mittel da sind wegen diesem ganzen Ownership-Geschichten. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, er wird dort mit Sicherheit Stammspieler sein, denn der aktuelle Torhüter hat zu oft gepatzt in den letzten Monaten, Jahren, würde ich fast sagen, obwohl man große Stücke auf ihn hält. Muss ich noch mal seinen Namen kurz nachgucken. Ich kann ihm nie merken, Gassaniga heißt der. Naja, und deswegen wird er dort spielen. Und er wird spielen bei einem Mittelklasse-Club, was heißt, er kriegt auch ordentlich Bälle vor die Nase gedroschen. Und auch das ist eigentlich wieder eine gute Geschichte, denn klar, wenn du bei Barca oder Real oder wie auch immer im Tor stehst, da kommen halt 2, 3 Schüsse vielleicht. Und da kriegt er halt jetzt 20, 30 Dinger auf das Tor und da kann er sich jetzt auszeichnen. Chirona hat gerade einen guten Lauf. Wie gesagt, die waren weit unten, kommen jetzt gerade nach oben. Wenn er denen jetzt hilft, mit guten Paraden vielleicht sich noch vorne wieder reinzuspielen, who knows? Für ihn ist es auf jeden Fall so, dass er dort, glaube ich, jetzt einen Stammplatz hat. Der Trainer wollte ihn auch unbedingt haben. Er kann in Barcelona weiterhin leben bleiben. Er muss da nur eine Stunde rüberfahren nach Chirona. Und we will see, ob das dann auch für ihn gut läuft. Aber schon allein, dass er wieder in Arango in seinen Reihen hat, glaube ich, wird ihn beflügeln.
Schon lustig, dass der Vater Arango den jungen Marc-Andre Ter Stegen unter seine Fittiche genommen hat. Das sage ich jetzt einfach, auch wenn ich jetzt nicht weiß, wie viel er mit dem Torhüter wirklich zu tun hatte im Training. Außer dass er ihm die Bälle um die Ohren gepfiffen hat und jetzt ist es umgedreht. Aber das ist ja sowieso. Also Marc-Andre Ter Stegen, also wer dem jetzt nicht jeden Erfolg der Welt gönnt, da hat, glaube ich, die letzten Jahre nicht so wirklich aufgepasst.
Der hat den Fußball nie gelebt.
Also das ist wirklich viel gut. Danke Fabian, das habe ich jetzt noch mal gebraucht. Ist die Frage, ob Daniel da jetzt mithalten kann mit so viel Feel-Good?
Ja, so ein bisschen, ich kann es versuchen. Ich habe beim Blick auf die Tabelle in Keller gesehen, dass ein Verein namens Telstar so langsam wieder ein bisschen in Fahrt kommt. Das sind Aufsteiger, die sind in der Nähe von Amsterdam. Wir sind in einem Ort, Felsensee, die sind westlich von Amsterdam gelegen, in der Nähe vom Meer. Und da sind aufgestiegen, haben am vierten Spieltag vielleicht mal wegen Eindhoven gewonnen und danach lange nicht mehr. Aber jetzt kommen wir so ein bisschen in Fahrt. Da haben wir es gegen die Almere gewonnen, gegen den Konkurrenten unten. Und jetzt haben wir jetzt den Punkt geholt gegen Excelsior. Das heißt, da kann man so ein bisschen hoffen. Und ich hoffe auch, wer aller Neutralität zum Trotz, würde es mich sehr freuen, wenn die die Klasse halten. Ich war auch vergangenes Jahr persönlich da. Und das ist für alle Crown-Topper und Crown-Topperinnen eine dringende Empfehlung, da mal hinzugehen. Also das ist ein richtiges kleines Schmuckkästchen. Es sind drei oder viertausend fast nur da rein in das Stadion. Und es ist einfach wirklich so eine richtige Crown-Topper-Amosphäre. Also das Stadion ist quasi so äquivalent zu so einem soliden Dritteliger-Stadion hier in Deutschland, würde ich sagen. Aber einfach flutliche Atmosphäre, sehr, sehr arbeiterstillastig. Man kommt dann mit so einem Bus, wo man da hinfahren, weil da infrastrukturell nicht so viele Erbindungen sind. Aber man kann zum Beispiel mit dem Bus hinfahren, recht schnell. Man ist dann in so einem schönen Nieselregen, dann in diesem wirklichen Stadion, mit viel Baulichenlehrraum zwischen drinnen. Und die haben zum Beispiel auch super Geschichte. Die wurden in den 60ern gegründet. Und der Name TellStar kommt von diesem ersten Ferran-Satelliten, der damals in die Umlaufbahn da gegeben wurde. Das fanden die einfach toll. Deswegen dachten die sich, wir nennen uns TellStar.
Ich war froh, dass sie sich nicht im Jahr der Toaster-Erfindung gegründet haben.
Und der hat den Namen TellStar. Und der hat auch sehr, sehr– das sind die weißen Löwen in der Beinahme. Und sie ist reich Tradition. Also Louis-Françal war da auch Spieler, glaube ich der bekannteste überhaupt. Aktuell im Tor spielt der Sohn von Ronald Koeman mit dem schönen Namen Ronald Koeman im Juniore. Also auch wieder bei den Söhnen und Töchtern in der Profis. Und die reich Tradition ist ein Kultclub, sage ich mal, aber nicht irgendwie ironisch abwertend gemeint, sondern wirklich ernsthaft. Und wenn man mal in der Nähe von Amsterdam ist, kann man gut mal, wenn es in die Planung passt, ein Bus nehmen und über Haarlem dahin fahren. Es lohnt sich schon. Stimmung ist top und Reichtradition, viel Geschichte.
Das war ein schönes Thema, ich sage es ganz ehrlich. Vielleicht zweitbekanntes der Name nach Louis Van Raal, der bei Telstar begonnen hat, ist Jimmy Floyd Hasselbank. Der kommt auch dort her. Und ansonsten noch nur ein kleiner Fun-Fact, Jeffrey Snyder, also der Bruder von Wesley. Der hat dort auch seine Karriere begonnen. Sehr schön. Telstar benannt nach einem Satelliten. Warum auch nicht. Dann können wir doch nochmal, Jakob, wenn du willst, in die Liga 1 rüberblicken. Was gibt es denn da noch zu erzählen?
Ich glaube, beim Namen von Paris FC ist relativ klar, wonach das benannt ist. Und es ist ja tatsächlich das erste Mal seit Ewigkeiten, dass es auch aus der französischen Hauptstadt zwei Teams gibt, die in der ersten Liga spielen, seitdem Paris FC letzten Sommer aufgestiegen ist. Allerdings so viel Hoffnung auf so eine riesige Feel-Good-Story ist da ja nicht, denn man muss sagen, Paris FC ist weder der typische Aufsteiger noch– ja, beschreibt es so eine schöne Underdog-Story, denn Paris FC hat in diesem Sommer das größte Transferminus von allen Teams in Frankreich gehabt, hat also knapp 60 Millionen ausgegeben für neue Spieler. Es haben nur PSG und Strasbourg überhaupt, ansonsten Transferminus gemacht in Frankreich. Dadurch, dass man nicht so viele Fernseh-Einnahmen hat, sind die Vereine ja sehr abhängig von Transfer erlösen. Man hat im Hintergrund ja mit der Arnaud-Familie, das wurde hier ja auch schon mal angesprochen, hatte David auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, auch sehr, sehr reiche Eigentümer, dann ja noch eine Minderheitsbeteiligung von Red Bull, was also auch ein bisschen zum Multi-Club-Ownership-Thema treibt. Aber bei Paris FC läuft es jetzt gar nicht so gut. Ich glaube, viele hatten auch aufgrund der Finanzstärke erwartet, dass man vielleicht sich direkt in der oberen Tabellenhefte etablieren könnte. Auf jeden Fall hatten die meisten eher das Gefühl, dass man vielleicht jetzt nicht so wirklich was mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben müsste. Und das sieht jetzt bisher eher anders aus. Also man ist jetzt nicht in akuter Abstiegsgefahr, hat jetzt auch am letzten Wochenende einen sehr wichtigen 2 zu 1-Sieg gegen Nantes eingefahren, sonst wäre man ganz tief unten drin gewesen. Jetzt hat man momentan fünf Punkte Vorsprung auf eben dieses Nantes, die auf Relegationsrang 16 stehen. Aber für das, was Paris FC im Sommer ausgegeben hat, ist das Ganze, glaube ich, sehr, sehr enttäuschend. Ich habe das ja auch häufiger schon gesagt, dass viele von den Teams, die unten drin sind, eigentlich gar kein Geld haben, um Ablösesummen zu bezahlen. Also wenn dann mal so ein, zwei Millionen für einen Spieler pro Transferphase– und bei Paris FC sah das jetzt ganz anders aus von den Transfers, die sie geholt haben –,Haben auch viele jetzt noch nicht so gut funktioniert. Also zum Beispiel hat man ja für 17 Millionen den Innenverteidiger Otavio von Porto geholt. Der spielt bisher eine sehr enttäuschende Saison, gefällt mir bisher wirklich überhaupt nicht gut. Dann hat man Moses Simon geholt von Nantes, also einem direkten Konkurrenten. Hätte ich mir relativ viel von erwartet, weil der eigentlich immer so der Schlüsselspieler bei Nantes war, funktioniert jetzt auch bei Paris FC noch nicht so richtig gut. Und allgemein ja die Transferbilanz jetzt nicht so richtig super. Man hat jetzt im Winter auch schon zweimal nachgelegt. Noch hat Luca Corleoscho ausgeliehen von Burnley, der jetzt auch gegen Normt direkt den entscheidenden Siegtreffer gemacht hat und hat Marshal Munizzi ausgeliehen aus Wolverhampton. Mal schauen, wie die jetzt beide einschlagen. Auf jeden Fall Munizzi wird im zentralen Mittelfeld eine Lücke schließen, die schon so vorhanden ist. Dadurch, dass da auch mit Pierre-Lés Melou, ein Spieler, den man von Stad Brest, also auch einem Liga-Konkurrenten, die ja auch letzte Saison sogar noch Champions League gespielt haben. Aber da konnte auch Stad Brest nicht finanziell mithalten bei dem Angebot, was Paris FC gemacht hat. Der fällt jetzt schon seit längerem aus. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Spieler, der Paris FC auch sehr fehlt. Man hatte zu Saisonbeginn vor allem das Gefühl, dass die Defensive das Problem ist. Man hat schon relativ viele Gegentore gefangen. Aber jetzt auch die Offensive läuft nicht so richtig rund, obwohl da auch Spieler sind, wo man eigentlich das Gefühl hat, okay, da müsste mehr gehen. Also Jonathan Ikone war ja auch mal vor ein paar Jahren ein ganz großer Name, als er bei Lille eine überragende Saison gespielt hat und dann ja auch in Italien war eine Zeit lang. Da weiß ich nicht so genau, wie er performt hat. Dann hat man auch Willem Gjöbelz noch, ein, ja, der früher auch mal als sehr, sehr großes Talent galt, unter anderem auch bei Monaco, der in der Schweiz jetzt getroffen hatte, jetzt in der Ligue 1 auch, ja, nicht so richtig performt bisher. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall ein paar bekannte Namen dabei. Und eigentlich müsste man mit der Mannschaft, glaube ich, auch deutlich besser spielen. Es gibt jetzt noch nicht so richtig Gerüchte darum, ob Stefan Geli, der Trainer, der auch seit 2023 schon im Amt ist, wirklich unter Druck steht. Ich glaube auch nicht unbedingt, dass das der Fall sein wird. Er hat ja jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen so ein bisschen den Eindruck erweckt, als würde er den Kurs korrigieren können. Ich meine, der Pokalerfolg gegen PSG, über den wir schon kurz gesprochen hatten, war natürlich ein Riesenerfolg und auch eine echte Sensation natürlich, dass PSG jetzt mal den Pokal nicht gewinnen wird. Er hat auch, um die Defensive zu stabilisieren, Kevin Trapp inzwischen die Pfosten gestellt, der ja zu Saisonbeginn, glaube ich, für viele überraschend, also erstmal, dass er überhaupt dahin gewechselt ist, kam ja schon überraschend, dass er dann aber noch nicht mal gespielt hat, war dann doch durchaus merkwürdig erstmal mit Oberton Cambadio, hat Paris FC auch einen sehr talentierten Keeper, der aber noch nicht so wirklich reif wirkte für die Liga, hat fünf Tore mehr kassiert als es nach Expected Goals wahrscheinlich wäre in seinen Einsätzen und hat jetzt seinen Stammplatz verloren. Kevin Trapp macht das bisher auch ganz solide, auch wenn, glaube ich, jeder weiß, wo auch er seine Schwächen durchaus hat, aber ich glaube, er hilft der Mannschaft jetzt mit seiner Erfahrung schon auch auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man bei Paris FC jetzt wirklich im Abstiegskampf reden muss, aber gerade angesichts des Ungleichgewichts zwischen dem Anspruch, den sie sicherlich haben, dem, was sie signalisiert haben mit ihren hohen Transfer-Ausgaben und der dann tatsächlichen sportlichen Performance ist das nicht so ganz stark. Und da passt auch zu, dass der eigentlich beste Spieler bisher in dieser Saison, Ilan Keball, einer ist, der schon ein bisschen länger da ist, also noch vor dieser riesigen Einkaufsphase unter der Ano-Familie dann gekommen war. Der hat jetzt, glaube ich, schon 11 Scorer gesammelt, war auch beim Afrika Cup dabei und ist jetzt aber auch wieder zurück. Also, auf den kann man auf jeden Fall mal ein Auge haben. Der hat auch einen sehr schönen und sehr, sehr starken linken Fuß, schießt echt nette Tore teilweise und ist ein Spieler, den man auf jeden Fall gerne zugucken mag.
Also ja, Paris FC, also man hat das mitbekommen mit dem PSG. Es waren ja zwei PSG-Spiele nacheinander. In einem stand Trapp im Tor, bei dem, was sie gewonnen haben, dann nicht, aber das war, was eben Pokal war. Jeweils 30 Prozent Ballbesitz in einem Spiel hatten sie 6 zu 23 Schüsse. Das haben sie 1 zu 2 verloren. Im anderen hatten sie 4 zu 20 Schüsse. Das haben sie 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Also das ordnet auch diese Sensation so ein bisschen ein. Das läuft gerade noch nicht so. Aber es ist ja vielleicht auch ein ganz schönes Signal, dass man nicht alles mit Geld sich kaufen kann. Zumindest kurzfristig. Lasst mir diesen glauben.
Ja gut, den Nicht-Abstieg wird man sich zumindest kaufen können. Also so ein bisschen Hoffenheim-Wolfsburg mäßig wird vielleicht auch jetzt in dieser Transferphase nochmal Geld drauf gekippt und dann steigt man zumindest nicht ab.
Okay, cool. Dann blicken wir nochmal ein letztes Mal nach Italien. Und gut, fröhlich wird es jetzt auch nicht, Mario.
Ja, schwierig jetzt irgendwie eine Feel-Good-Story daraus zu machen, dass ein Mensch von uns gegangen ist, Rocco B. Comisso, der Präsident der Fiorentina, ist im Alter von 76 Jahren gestorben. Aber dennoch so ein bisschen, weil wir es jetzt gerade auch immer von Multi-Club-Ownership hatten etc., so ein bisschen der Gegenentwurf und vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Geschichte einer schillernder Persönlichkeit, die ihn in guter Erinnerung behalten lässt. Und ich finde schon auch in Italien ist immer, da sind natürlich auch, und er gehört da auch dazu, superreiche Geschäftsmänner, Präsidenten von Vereinen. Dennoch habe ich ganz oft das Gefühl, dass es was anderes ist. Also ist es auch in Napoli mit einem wilden Charakter, der aber stets auch so ein wenig Fan des Vereins ist, was Rocco B. Comisso auch war. Ein Junge damals, der mit 12 aus Kalabrien in die USA ausgewandert ist, das sehr, sehr viel Geld gemacht hat, dort aber auch schon viel davon in Fußball investiert hat. Unter anderem war er Mitbesitzer von New York Cosmos und hat da so ein bisschen die Mitweite entwickelt. Da kam letztes Jahr eine Geschichte raus, weil es da auch Streits gab zwischen der MLS und den eher sozusagen Amateur-Ligen, wo er dann– das muss 2017 gewesen sein– und letztes Jahr, als es eine Gerichtsverhandlung dazu gab, hat er zugegeben, dass er Fake-Twitter-Accounts genutzt hat. Damals gab es Twitter-Accounts, die einen der Geschäftsführer der MLS aufs Übelste beleidigt haben und dann hat sich rausgestellt, das war Rocco Bicomiso himself, der dort ganz derbe Worte gewählt hatte. 2019 hat die höchstmarode Fiorentina übernommen und da wirklich, also in den letzten Jahren, oft im Conference League-Finale, spannende Trainer, die da groß geworden sind, hat ein großes Leistungszentrum bauen lassen, das altehrwürdige Stadion Atemio Franky, das jetzt umgebaut wurde. Das hat er auch noch mit angeschoben. Und da habe ich auch so eine kleine persönliche Geschichte. In diesem Stadion war ich einmal und war auf der Haupttribüne und in diese Tribüne eingelassen ist die Präsidentenloge, die so ein wenig daherkommt, wie ja so ein Balkon im Theater, wo er in der Mitte sitzt. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als würdest du eigentlich gar nicht reinpassen, so von den baulichen Maßnahmen. Und da sitzt er, droht er auf Höhe der Mittellinie. Aber alle Menschen, die vorbeigekommen sind, Frauen, Kinder, Omas, Opas, ich auch, als ich da hochgeguckt habe, hat er auch gerade runtergeguckt zu mir und meinem Sohnemann, wie wir da hochgekommen sind, guckt dann runter, grüßt, hat sich auch in der Halbzeit mit Leuten unterhalten. Also einer, der das sehr gelebt hat, was glaube ich auch gerade an dem Standort Italien sehr wichtig ist für die Anerkennung rund um den Verein. Also die haben ihn da wirklich sehr geschätzt. Und ja, die letzten Wochen, Monate war er auch seltener da, was dann so ein bisschen komisch wahrgenommen wurde. Auch der Fiorentiner ging es ja gar nicht gut. Langtabellenletzter gewesen. Da hat sich jetzt halt rausgestellt, dass er krank war und auch deswegen nicht dort war. Und ja, anlässlich seines Todes Tages hat dann die Fiorentiner auch endlich mal ihr erstes Auswärtsspiel gewonnen und ist jetzt nicht mehr auf den Abstiegsplätzen. Also vielleicht spielt diese Mannschaft so ein bisschen die Saison für ihn auch mit zu Ende. Und weil ich es ganz schön fand und gerade jetzt irgendwie in Diskussionen um Multi-Club-Ownership auch reinpasste, habe ich einen Ausschnitt aus dem Nachruf aus der SZ mitgebracht von dem geschätzten Kollegen Felix Haselsteiner, der geschrieben hat, bemerkenswert ehrlich war Komiso stets. Manchmal auch derb. Die Angelis, Besitzerfamilie von Juventus Turin, nannte er mal Motherfuckers in seinem typisch Italo-Englisch. Wie eine Figur aus einem Film von Scorsese oder Coppola klang er dann. Wie ein Mann aus einer alten Welt, der sich von seinem Instinkt und seinem Menschenverständnis leiten ließ. Wie ein Gegenentwurf zu den Investoren und Zahlen-Jongleuren, die den Fußball als Geschäft sehen, nicht als Liebesaffäre.
Mario, das ist so witzig. Ich wollte genau diesen Absatz hätte ich jetzt vorgegeben, wenn du es nicht gemacht hättest. Das ist einfach fantastisch. Aber die Fiorentiner und Todesfälle, das ist ja wirklich Wahnsinn, was sich da summiert hat. Also ohne das jetzt irgendwie einen komischen Kontext rücken zu wollen. Aber ja, da ist noch jemand der alten Garde gegangen.
Und nicht nur Astori, den du gerade angesprochen hast, den Kapitän, der vor vielen Jahren gestorben ist. Auch so diese Geschichte noch mit Bove, mit dem Herzstillstand auf dem Feld, der leider in Italien aufgrund der Gesetzgebung nicht spielen darf. Aber ich nach England geht, meine ich jetzt.
Wattford ist glaube ich fix.
Oh Gott, Wattford, da habe ich jetzt auch schon wieder diesen Begriff auf den Lippen, den wir hatten. Aber wir machen es zu jetzt.
Ja, machen wir es einfach zu hier. Ihr Lieben, das hat große Freude gemacht. Die erste Ligatour Europa dieses Jahres 2026 und auch in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer wird es jetzt dann weitergehen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Also abonniert einfach diesen Feed oder diesen Kanal und dann werdet ihr das nicht verpassen. Ab jetzt kommen wir wieder in unsere Rotation rein. Ich danke euch fünf sehr, sehr herzlich Chris McAfee, Daniel Zehnder, Jakob Haffke, Fabian Pakulat und Mario Rieker. Ich werde natürlich verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ja, und vielen, vielen Dank für eure Zeit und eure Vorbereitung in eure Themen. Danke euch. Ja, da wird genickt. Ihr müsst einfach glauben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da wurde genickt. Dann danke ich doch auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, alles hier im Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Und warum? Weil ihr uns finanziell unterstützt. Auf rasenfunk.de und natürlich auch in der Podcast- und Videobeschreibung erfahrt ihr, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Geht auf allen erdenklichen Wegen. Und dann könnt ihr euch ja einfach überlegen, welchen Gegenwert, welchen monetären Wert hat denn so eine Sendung wie diese hier für euch. Und auch an dieser Stelle noch mal der Hinweis, zum 1.1. haben wir, wie ab jetzt dann immer, unsere Gästehonorare um 3% erhöht. Das heißt, wenn ihr wollt, dann könnt ihr das doch auch gerne zum Anlass nehmen, vielleicht auch eure Unterstützung, um diesen Prozentsatz oder, wenn ihr wollt, auch mehr zu erhöhen erhöhen. Deswegen vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei JWS, bei Kickers, Emden, Maniac und bei Wolfgang. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann ist mitmachen.rasenfunk.de der perfekte Ort dafür. Und dann hören wir uns ja bald schon wieder, denn wenn ihr auch nur einen anderen Feed vom Rasenfunk abonniert habt, dann wisst ihr, wir hauen gerade Sendungen raus wie warme Semmeln. In diesem Sinne, bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!